there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey here we are again it's saturday
[ __ ] yeah i am so
tired and we're like 12
we're like 12 subscribers away from
hitting 10 000. something like that we
may have already hit we didn't hit it
yet yeah have we no
you're looking at that we're so close
you guys are getting 10.
i don't even know what we're going to do
when we hit 10 000 subscribers i'm just
so excited about it
i feel like we should do something i
wish i had confetti or some [ __ ] yeah
or balloons i don't know it's gonna be a
good case today there's gonna be a case
about uh damn
porn star murder i was gonna dress up
because before
we were discussing this yesterday
i was gonna start this new thing where i
dress up in a costume each one related
to
related to whatever the topic is right
so we should totally do that this one's
this is this one's related to john
holmes so i was just going to take
some socks and [ __ ] roll them up
stuff them in my pants
and have that [ __ ] like coming around
here like this yeah i said
we're talking about john holmes yeah you
need a 13 inch 14 inch i can't remember
that would have been my john holmes
costume just have like a damn
peach and throw it down
and [ __ ] braid it so you got some
girth to it
put that [ __ ] in your pants and [ __ ] i'm
right-handed so it goes off to the left
like that
and yeah you dress to that side that's
what they used to say back in the world
i don't know how i know that yeah yeah
that [ __ ]
that'd have been awesome but i i backed
out of it i was like nah
you also need like john holmes terrible
hair yeah
and also his terrible smoked sunglasses
well it wasn't just him because
everybody had that terrible [ __ ] like in
the [ __ ] 70s so it wasn't
just actually i was thinking about just
uh
another thing that i could have done is
just dress up in a costume that is in no
way related to the [ __ ] subject which
is kind of more what i would do
that would even be better like just show
up with my hulk hogan mustache and a
[ __ ]
bandage and just don't know anything
about it yeah it's [ __ ] horrible
[ __ ] yellow glasses and [ __ ]
you know hulkamania stuff you know what
i don't know what i'm not wearing it's
not even [ __ ] mention it that'd be
what are you talking about these are
just my clothes
yeah that's kind of that would be
actually really funny yeah well it
wouldn't be funny now because we just
said about it
yeah so we're trying we're gonna try to
keep the show upbeat and fun today i'm
i'm
[ __ ] gonna start pounding this liquor
everybody's pissed off
so we're gonna [ __ ] just go ahead and
i'm not pissed off i'm just sleepy
yeah sleepy and [ __ ] because you woke
me up
yeah do you know what he did this
morning you guys he woke up like
i very specifically said last night i
watched a movie that we're going to
review tomorrow
like on shutter oh hey i got my new
shutter shirt can you guys see it
yeah i got it from freight racks it's
underneath all them boobies it's
well it's not underneath okay on top
it's on top of it okay
yeah but yeah so uh yeah it's very nice
shirt i got because i'm because i
got the banner going you can't see it
see well wait can you see
hold on we're gonna have to [ __ ]
raise your shirt there you go raise your
hand there you go
it says look it says so good at scary on
it yeah i feel like i got a medium but
it's like two
it's big yeah they're big it's bit no i
mean the shirt is big
douche yeah the shirt actually looks a
little bit like a large it doesn't look
like a medium to be
i know well that's the thing well see i
usually i mean normally i
if people are like okay well it's
women's size i usually get a small
because i don't want like a big baggy
tent kind of [ __ ]
um that's just my personal preference
yeah but
sometimes i'm like well i've got a
couple of shirts that said they were
small
and they were like really small like i
can still wear them but
you know it's like they're i look like a
baby shirt
so i said well i'll get a medium this
time and then the medium's too big
but it's all right it's comfy at least
but um i just
totally forgot where i was going with
that oh so i watched a movie on shutter
i watched some more halloween wars
because halloween's every day
[ __ ] and i'm
not ready to let go of halloween yet so
i'm still watching that [ __ ] on hulu
and i specifically said i mean saturday
is kind of the only day that i get to
sleep in you know what i mean because we
don't do the show till five
um you know i don't get up early and go
work out or whatever like i do during
the week
so i'm just like oh man it's gonna be so
awesome maybe it'll rain and i'll be
sleeping it'll be
[ __ ] cool i woke up at like 5
30 because i had to pee like usual and
then pookie jumps on my face and i'm
like okay whatever go to bed
and then i was trying desperately to go
back to sleep
and then you woke up and then i could
hear you fumbling with your headphones
yeah and like kick in and whatever it is
that you do and then all of a sudden you
said very loudly
growth yeah growth and i was like
yeah i was so angry yeah i was like i
was trying
to sleep i remember why do you do these
things to me
i was waking up i've been and i've i
have not woken up all day long
i've had so much coffee so i'm like
super caffeinated and super tired at the
same time
i was waking up all right i was halfway
in and out of sleep
i was [ __ ] real sore you know what i
mean from like the from like the two
days before
workout you know i mean it was sore for
a while but then like
you get this weird stiff limb feeling
you know what i mean
and it's this it's the feeling that you
get when you're growing
that's what it was and it has whatever
he thinks it has to come out of his
mouth well i was mad about it
all right and it was happening as i was
waking up growth
god damn i don't know and i was like god
damn
and then i tried to go to sleep
i sat up that's a [ __ ] it i'm gonna take
a shower because there's no way i was
gonna go back to sleep
i went to sleep early well yeah i did
too but i woke up a bunch of times
right like i had like i had like kinda
i had kind of like locked up like i was
[ __ ] real stiff
you know what i mean and it's from it's
from that [ __ ] that i take
you know he doesn't have any hormones
i'm always i'm always awesome
dudes are so hormonal they should not be
allowed to run [ __ ] and it like
growth i was like
really really then i got up i told you
last night that i was like so excited
that i could
sleep in on saturday morning well it's
like it didn't happen it goes back
to my to my [ __ ] um my uh what do you
call it
tourette syndrome it's yeah i don't know
what it is it's
it has to do with the hemispheres of my
brain they're highly integrated they're
not set they're not
separated very well you know what i'm
talking about sure so
my spatial awareness my verbal acuity
and all that [ __ ]
they they interact a lot with themselves
and sometimes like what i'm
thinking comes out always what you're
thinking comes from right
pretty much if i'm relaxed yeah if i'm
relaxed if i'm [ __ ] doing something
and real
into it then no because because it's
kind of like it kind of i get started
getting real disciplined and
it all kind of comes together but when
i'm relaxed it's just kind of
i'm kind of like going off yeah you're
constantly talking yeah because it's
well because he has his um because i
need quiet when i sleep
yeah um he does not he likes noise yeah
i have to have noise so he
has to have like he has his tablet and
he always like listens to stuff with his
headphones like to get him to go to
sleep
and i'll react to something but he'll
react to something like on
so it's not like i mean it's usually
cuss words like oh [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
yeah it's like [ __ ] like that but he'll
say it like in a normal voice and i'm
like
some of us are trying to sleep over here
on the other side of the bed remember it
happens it happens as i start
as i start to relax and i'm in between
awake and sleep like you know
in the liminal mistakes
that's the time i think all that poultry
guys stuff kind of happens well probably
yeah you know
and and like i said you're not the first
person to have said that when you when
you're in like a state where you're not
really asleep and not really awake yeah
like kind of hypnagogic or whatever they
call it
it doesn't it doesn't um it's weird
because it's a combination it's like a
bunch of voices
you know what i mean some of them are my
voices some of them some of them are the
voices of people that i remember
who were who said something to me some
of them are the voices of
characters or something you know what i
mean kind of like you
my mind is a [ __ ] constant stream of
voices
if you understand what i'm talking about
do you know do you have that sometimes
yeah but i hate to alarm you but that's
one of the
um i'm pretty sure that's one of the
symptoms of schizophrenia
it might be i don't know i don't know
you know what i think it's just it's
just uh
well my memories are very strong
so if i remember something i kind of see
it
yeah i got it and everybody in that
memory is [ __ ] talking and then the
comp and then
and it usually hap it's usually very
condensed it's only a few seconds
yeah no i mean it's not happening in
real time
dj maniac says when i first started
listening to the show i listened to you
guys when i was trying to fall asleep
i would not advise that he says that
[ __ ] went out the window as soon as tom
started yelling
yeah this is not a like kind of sleepy
kind of show
if you want to go to sleep like listen
to you know my
uh my witching hour show or maybe my
book reviews hopefully they're not that
boring but at least you don't have
yeah tom like yelling at ranting
everything and kill breaking it with the
[ __ ]
just my smooth sonorous voice yeah but
uh
yeah so whatever you know you can make
fun of me and [ __ ]
or whatever no i no i didn't say that
you were
i just said i didn't want to alarm you
but i'm pretty sure that now
that is legitimately um yeah but i've
seen schizophrenic people say it doesn't
look like yeah i have to
but i'm just i you know i'm kind of
joking but yeah
no it's just uh you know you know like
that skinny puppy i have a mind
perpetual intercourse yes
it's like that yeah you know it's
constant and and i've also read about it
that the hemispheres are talking to each
other
yeah things are worked out between the
two some of them
you know some of this [ __ ] happens
automatically you don't even think about
it like if if an object falls
you catch it before you even knew that
it's falling
that's i think the right hemisphere
that's doing that or the left i think
you know what's interesting though i
think in general is that uh
the corpus callosum you know the thing
that connects the two hemispheres is
actually much larger in
women yeah um so they're the two halves
of their brains
generally um communicate better better
yeah um
with each other than men's brains do but
i don't know if that's the case in your
case yeah you don't think so i don't
know
it's hard to say i was just you're a
special case
in all regards oh thank you aaron thank
you so much
happy saturday happy saturday thank you
thank you so much
no i just [ __ ] woke up saying growth
that's what i was thinking about
that's my next t-shirt i'm going to have
like a little cartoon
tom going like this going growth and
then me like over here like all sleepy
going
i so wanted to go back to sleep well i
was fighting it
growth was [ __ ] me up it had me all
[ __ ] stiff and [ __ ]
you have to be there you have to be in
my shoes at the time to understand
you know what i mean i i gotcha i gotcha
i think also
also growing up an only child has a lot
to do with it too baby
maybe it's their own interaction all the
time
we've kind of talked about that before
because you had a much different
experience growing up than i did i was
only an only child until i was four
and then my brother was born i was
always an only child and so i have three
siblings
right all younger so you basically had
to
you know it would and and i actually
really get along with all my siblings
they're all very we're all very similar
which is weird even though we're like
really like far apart in age
um but you really had to it had to be
like a whole negotiation of like what
[ __ ] was going on you know what i mean
yeah not with me we didn't fight much
though me and my siblings i don't
remember us fighting all that much
that's not the experience i had growing
up well yeah it's kind of like autonomy
it must be really weird i always thought
it must be really weird being up so like
i was friends with
people that were only children and i
just always thought that was really
strange
i don't really remember being an only
child because like i said i was only
four when my brother was born so
from my point of view well when you're
an only child you're kind of like an
island
it's just you yeah you know what i mean
and you get all the attention
uh yeah but they that may not
necessarily be good although no it's not
so i mean so it's just kind of like uh
i don't know it's not like normal for me
the best thing about having siblings
negotiations involved and i'm not saying
that i did this because like i said me
and my siblings got along
but the best thing about having siblings
other than
getting to trade all your halloween
candy for like [ __ ] you actually like
is if something bad happens in the house
you can go yeah that one did it they did
it was it me
you can blame it on the other one i
would never do that because i'm a nice
person
but i'm just saying that that option is
on the table
[Laughter]
that's all i'm saying everybody's here
everybody's here
got sophis here what's up so dj maniacs
in here
fort drawer beads nest badgers in here
michael shafe schaefer
sheila sam michael shafer says i feel
like
i sound like a bowl of rice krispies
when i get up in the morning yeah you
owe me both man
i know that feeling yeah my well my
knees have clicked since i was
in my 20s so it's not anything new i
guess
i don't feel any older than i
[Laughter]
that i did sb says i'm pregnant at the
moment and it's hell so this kid will be
an only child i'm not doing this torture
ever again
that's what mom said what yeah and i
can't blame anybody for that although i
do
think for and i don't know if this is
the case in everyone's situation but
um a lot of times like it'll say oh your
body makes you forget the pain so you'll
have another one like you'll forget how
shitty it was
you know what i mean although i don't
know
i've heard so i've heard women say that
like after after the first one it's
easier
each one is easier and easier yeah it
depends on the thing usually the first
one is
the worst like uh pain wise like the
length of
uh you know length of uh how long you're
in labor [ __ ] like that
not always but that's usually the
situation
um and also something that i found that
i'm not saying this is
necessarily true in mind but you have
your first kid you don't have [ __ ]
know what you're doing i mean my parents
had me when they were 18 so they really
didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
doing
but i didn't figure that out until later
they from my point of view they did
totally fine i wasn't
i never like thought of them not doing
fine so
um but the more kids you have like the
less
of a [ __ ] you give you know what i mean
because you're like you go through the
first one and you're like super worried
because you've never had one before and
you don't know like how it works and
stuff
but then like once you've gone through
all the [ __ ] with the first kid which
was me in my case
um you know you have more and you're
just like oh it's fine
whatever there's just plain traffic i
don't i don't care you know what i mean
so it kind of goes in that direction
where you're not helicopter parent all
the time so i do feel like
being an only child like i said it might
be good in some cases because you get
all the
attention and all the like money spent
on you and all the love and everything
like that
but in another way you might have your
parents like up your ass
24 7. that's usually which is not ideal
you know what i'm saying yeah either
that or they're trying to [ __ ] groom
you for greatness that will never happen
that type of [ __ ]
well that's another thing too is that if
you have siblings
if you have siblings and you [ __ ] your
life up or you don't do what your
parents wanted
you're just kind of like hey because see
the thing
okay now i'm gonna why aren't you a
doctor yet you're 12.
right you're 12. well see here's the
thing and like this is bad because i
feel like well i was the oldest and it's
like my mom was always like you should
have kids because my mom loves kids and
i'm
not a fan um generally so
uh you know but in a way it was good
that i had a bunch of siblings because
then i was like i had some of the
pressure taken off me because i was just
because
my brother and his wife have uh two kids
of their own and two kids that were
uh you know my sister-in-law's kids from
a previous relationship so they have
four kids
so i'm just like look i'm covered okay i
got covered
so i didn't have to like worry about it
like my parents weren't all like
my our line is ending with you blah blah
blah so whether you know there wasn't
any of that
i had somebody else to like take the
[ __ ]
to take the bullet
although i will say that my other
siblings also have not reproduced
because they are
like me i guess not not a big fan of
children
i hope do you know we have pookie
that's like that's like my kid so all
right
looks like tila is an only child too and
i think yeah
sophie's i don't think i didn't think
soph was an only child i thought she had
a sister
so yeah so if you have a sister right
yeah what the hell you taught myself
so i was trying to claim to be a [ __ ]
only child you're not an only child i
have one sister and two brothers
yeah all younger like i said but they're
all in their 30s and 40s she's the
oldest
that's not the same as an only child
yeah cause like i said i'm the oldest
too
but i was only four years old when my
little brother was the oldest child
usually just becomes a cop
a cop over the other children i'll tell
that kind of stuff yeah you better do
this that it's
i've heard that but that doesn't that
didn't happen in our situation
um i actually when my brother was born
and he was a baby
yeah because i i think what usually
happens is the older kid is like oh [ __ ]
i'm being replaced by the cute baby or
whatever
um i had the opposite reaction like when
my little brother was born i'm like oh
my god
look at him he's like so awesome and my
family said you used to carry that
little kid around yeah
everywhere and there's like a bunch of
pictures of me like hanging out with my
little boo
with the little little boy like i used
to wag him around all over
the place and like play with him and
stuff and like i said even when we got
older we were like actually
we were actually really close because we
were very similar like in personality we
had like a lot of the same interests and
stuff
we were all into like punk rock and [ __ ]
like that so everybody's talking about
their brothers and sisters and [ __ ] in
the comments
that's fine tom can't relate no
he can't relate i love my siblings
i love my siblings i really do and like
when we all get together like i said
it's really cool because there's like a
weird like synergy like we all like
finish each other's sentences and stuff
it's like super creepy and i know that
all siblings aren't like that
but we are even though we're very far
apart in age
which i've heard is very unusual
i'm glad i didn't have to go through it
i've no it's
it's a pleasurable experience i don't
think i would have liked being an only
child
i don't think i would have liked it i
don't know man i liked it
well yeah like i said it depends on the
pers like
i don't know i feel like i'm kind of a
loner nowadays but it's like i feel like
i'm glad that i had that experience i
didn't have to share anything you know
growing up in brazil it was just me see
i didn't mind that i didn't mind sharing
with people
i didn't like what was a big end to that
because they would they would have
divided everything in half
or in thirds or in thirds yeah something
like that
i know but but the thing is it's like
when
it's hard to explain i never got that um
i never got that feeling that i was
being like shortchanged or anything like
that
like oh we had to divide everything i
just never got that okay
i mean maybe other people that have
siblings like had a different experience
but i did not experience that like i
said i always got along well with my
siblings i did it didn't bother me
okay well uh should we get to the case
yeah oh uh
okay so before we go any further i
wanted to say a big thank you i think
he's in the
comments if i saw him earlier i wanted
to say thanks to michael e
for blessing us
to watch the mandalorian yes i must say
we made it to we it's season two episode
three that's what we're doing
yeah it's uh it's good i would i'm
liking it even better than the first and
i really really liked the first season
i'm really liking this one it's very
monster centric
yeah lots of baby yoda action it's good
hopefully they can keep it up
honestly i told i told you this last
night i was like
i would watch a whole show of baby yoda
doing baby yoda [ __ ]
just like he doesn't have to like talk
he could just like waddle around
and like they got people already like do
silly things they got people
already out there bitching that [ __ ]
the child was eating the damn frog eggs
and that it
and then yeah eating the frog woman's
eggs and that that's genocide and that
the baby's racist and [ __ ]
[ __ ] are these people [ __ ] serious
are they [ __ ] sick people someone's
trolling people
they're [ __ ] saying oh that's
terrible you know what i mean [ __ ]
that's and these are [ __ ] fan
people dress up i did feel i did feel
kind of nervous what the [ __ ] because i
was like that's not ladies babies baby
it's a [ __ ] tv show all right it's a
[ __ ] tv show
people i think what it is is that
there's so many people out there
that live vicariously through television
that they that they get confused and
they think television is real
there is no baby yoda that's a [ __ ]
doll there's a baby
right there yeah it's a doll okay and
there were no there was no
[ __ ] frog eggs you know it's just
ridiculous aaron says yoda and the eggs
was freaking killing me seriously i was
the best part of that
i would watch a whole show of that just
because it's just
it was so [ __ ] yeah just these
[ __ ] childish
like i felt bad because i was like man
it's like if that was my eggs i'd be
really pissed but it's like it was just
so funny the way he was like so
like covert yeah i didn't like [ __ ]
crack me up it was like pookie trying to
get away with that
it reminded me of that they you know
they're they were showing screenshots
from people on twitter [ __ ]
that's terrible [ __ ] you know the
child is supposed to be a being of light
and goodness and easy
it's a [ __ ] baby he's a baby and it's
enough he doesn't know any better and
like i said species eat each other it's
just food well the thing
well the thing that maybe didn't know
anything it was just sad that's what i
mean well the thing that
because you you kind of said it first
like when he was like looking at i hope
i'm not spoiling anything for anybody
that hasn't seen this episode
but um when he was just like looking at
the eggs and the dancing i thought he's
gonna do some good
you thought he was gonna do some good
[ __ ] i'm gonna like he's gonna eat that
[ __ ] yeah and then he did and i was like
see i called it
because he was looking at him in wonder
mint but he was hungry
yeah he's like those little oh those are
delicious it was just like that pickled
like jar of pickled eggs that you said
in 7-eleven
but yes the 7-eleven next to my
grandma's house but the thing about it
is that
they nailed that though because like i
said he's a baby
and babies that's the first thing they
do is they just put everything in their
mouth
they don't care what is and you know i
might have told this story before but
one of the funniest stories that i
remember from my ch
from you know when i was younger was
when my youngest brother
was still like a toddler and we were all
at the beach and he dropped
a cheese ball into the sand on the beach
and peed on it and then picked it up and
ate it before my mother could stop him
damn that's like something baby would do
that's what i mean babies just they
don't care what it is
they'll pick up a bug and be like huh
yeah so that's what i thought was funny
was that i just thought that was like
baby yoda being a baby like i'll just
stick everything in my [ __ ] face
because that's what you guys do yeah and
then amanda was like no
don't do that knock it off
what do you mean why can't i well like i
said it's just like when pookie tries to
sneak back into the house with a lizard
stuffed in her mouth it's that same look
and runs pat that's the same look that
poopy gives us
yup she's kind of what i don't have a
lizard i'm not eating it i swear to god
and then like you have to like
yeah get it out and then take the lizard
outside and the lizard's like thanks man
yeah it's like that so that's why i
thought it was funny
but yeah so uh i just wanted to say uh
thank you michael
for that michael says i haven't bothered
with star wars
since the last of the prequels uh this
is a lot better than
than um those last three movies the
mandalorian is super super
delorean's like real star wars it's
super fun yeah it's
it's like the other thing it doesn't
really have anything to do with like the
main narrative from like the big star
wars movies it's just kind of like an uh
you know it's kind of like a kind of
like a western an extended universe yeah
it all it reminds me of like star wars
crossed with like firefly
you know what i mean type of thing it's
serenity
it's it's very much kind of like um lone
wolf and cub which is a
japanese movie series i was going to
show it to
to which we reviewed you know but it's
four movies and it
takes too long that's something you have
to rent one one by one
and it's it's definitely inspired by
lone wolf and cub which is a japanese
samurai movie that had a lot of
western mixed in with it and that was
shintaro
shintaro brother was playing the damn
lead in it who's this samurai
executioner kind of guy
with this little baby with his son and
they were walking the path to hell and
[ __ ]
everybody was trying to kill him and um
it's that same concept
which fits right in because that's what
lucas wanted when lucas made star wars
he wanted it to be a mixture of samurai
movie and western
and in space with flash gordon you know
and uh so that's right there that's what
the mandalorian is i mean
on on that um on in seas in episode two
of season two
they went straight western with that one
was that season or was that episode one
no it's episode two i think it was
and well two was the one where he was
first
the first one was the crate dragon okay
yeah the crate dragon one
it was definitely like right out of
sergio leone uh
well yeah they set up a lot of the same
show like the way he came out of town
just full of dollars you know it's like
yeah great series great series hopefully
they can keep it up without [ __ ] it
up
and like i said so far we're only three
episodes in but i'm like and
i liked the first one a really loud but
this one i'm really because i like that
it's more like monster centric
i like that they're putting a little bit
more emphasis on baby yoda because
i you know baby yoda's just focusing
yeah we call it baby yoda everybody
calls it baby it is not yoda
i know just the child i know yeah and
everybody knows that
everybody knows don't don't well
actually everybody everybody knows it's
not yoda it's not yoda here
it's just another one of the species
that they never the mandalorian is
trying to bring it back take it back to
to its species to its people and he
doesn't know where that is
nobody knows where that is so yeah
that's what season two is that sounds
like his
quest to like take baby yoda back to
like to it to his home planet yeah
and then you know along the way he eats
people's eggs
gets eaten by a monster michael says
he's allergic to disney he's allergic
yeah i don't like disney either
yeah well you know like i said the
mandalorian is good
so just saying i i don't
i don't get all butt hurt about [ __ ]
like like some young people do
yeah it's a 50 year old baby it's a baby
and it's like 50.
well yeah but they live until they're
like 800 or 900 years old
so yeah it's gonna be a big deal for you
to be a baby yeah
which holy [ __ ] how annoying would that
be bad enough you gotta like cart around
a kid for a couple of years before they
can go to [ __ ] kindergarten
yeah 50 years carrying a [ __ ] baby
around
[ __ ] that [ __ ] just saying all right so
are we going to talk about the
wonderland markers now yeah if you want
to you ready ready to go
i guess how are you doing on that drink
you're all right on that i have about a
third of it left
it's good it's it's gotten very watered
down for whatever reason we made them
very early
do you want me to uh fix that no it's
probably better that it's watertight
because i'm drinking it i have water too
but it's like i'm drinking it really
quickly and i'm super tired so it's like
i might not be
coherent by the time this ends but like
i said
i here's something that's interesting i
did not
really know much about these murders and
i can't remember i
apologize i can't remember who it was
that recommended this to me first
because it's been in the topic box for
like a while and finally it came up on
the
rotation and everyone voted for it well
most people voted for it on patreon
so this is the one that we're gonna do
and then when i started looking into it
i was like holy [ __ ]
why is this not better known
maybe it is better known and i'm just
like out of it because i feel like look
the you know the manson murders
obviously which we haven't done a show
about amazingly
this crime was a lot more
brutal than that one but i guess
i guess the reason that this one doesn't
get as much play is because the victims
of it were not just innocent bystanders
you know what i'm saying yeah they were
all like kind of part of a drug gang
so it's kind of like everyone was like
right
well good riddance you know what i'm
saying well a lot of that goes on and
people don't know
about it crooks kill each other all the
time and it really doesn't make the
headlines
that's what i'm saying but i found this
really interesting just because of all
the
um connections all the [ __ ] that was
going on in la at the time like this was
early 1980s
and also the fact that uh john holmes
the very famous porn star
was possibly involved allegedly
um so you know so i found that
interesting
also there they made a movie called
wonderland
in 2003 with val kilmer in it playing
uh john holmes and that was actually a
really good movie it's actually on 2b if
you want to watch it for free because i
found it
and i watched it a day or two ago
and it's actually once i looked into the
case and like looked at all the [ __ ] i
watched a couple documentaries it was
like a british documentary about it
um the movie is actually pretty accurate
like to what happened
um and kind of tells like both because
there's a couple different
stories um so it kind of goes into that
a little bit as well but it's actually
like a
really good movie very star-studded like
i said val kilmer is in it
[ __ ] lisa kudrow is in it like uh
janine garofalo was in it like all these
like really kind of famous people were
in it
um so that was really good also
i was not aware but this was the crime
that you know that part in boogie nights
where they go to that um
where they go to that gangster's house i
think that it's a gangster is played by
alfred molina i want to say and he's
doing all the
in his like vietnamese house boy or
whatever he's doing all the fireworks
and then they like shoot everybody or
there's like a scene in the middle where
they like do a big like robbery and end
up killing a bunch of people
that was um very loosely based on
the wonderland murders because uh the
character of dirk digler
in boogie nights was actually very
loosely based on
john holmes which i was not
i was only like tangentially it was a
great movie i really didn't i love
boogie nights
i've seen it lost so many times i'm
gonna go ahead and give a shout out to
another movie in case you guys haven't
seen it it's called
moat and mope is not a well-known movie
i rented it on [ __ ] xbox i can't
believe this movie's not better known i
loved that movie
it's based on a real [ __ ] case it's
just like in
do you remember what they were called
what what their names were i can't
remember now it was these two we
reviewed the movie back
like a few two real [ __ ] low
ranking guys low-ranking porn star guys
they're called mopes yeah mopes are just
like porn extras that's what yeah in the
industry
one of them was like a black dude and
the other one was like was he chinese or
korean
the other guy oh i can't remember i
think it was something like that and
they were mopes
that's what they did and they were
trying to get
become famous leading porn stars but
these two dudes really didn't have what
it took okay
and they ended up being in a [ __ ]
murder and a suicide wasn't it
it was it was a multiple murder yeah and
then he killed himself
yeah but it's just a great movie you got
to see it's called mope
yeah it's like it's almost like a black
comedy yeah it's got a lot of comedy in
it but it starts going
terrible terrible story it starts going
real [ __ ] sideways
and um it's kind of like a dark version
of boogie nights if you like boogie
nights you might like this i mean boogie
nights gets pretty dark too i gotta say
darker but mope is like much darker i
actually want to get
mope on blu-ray to add to my collection
that's that's another one that was up
there i really did like that movie
and it's and it's just like a small
well-made
independent film when i saw it when we
saw it i was riveted i was immediately
pulled into it yeah me too
and and it's just the weirdest [ __ ]
happens in it
and it's you might be able to watch it
for free it might be out on tubie or
something i don't know
i don't know it's not x-rated but it's
heavy r i would think there's a lot of
sex and weird [ __ ] happens
yeah i mean it's about the porn industry
yeah and they don't really like shy away
from that kind of [ __ ] it's kind of like
a porn version of [ __ ]
um uh that martial arts movie that i
like
uh what was it called which one this the
art of self defense
oh right right kind of like art of self
it did like the tone of it
reminded me of it but it was about yeah
porn thank you tim
thanks tim i for some reason i find
i'm not like i i find movies about
the porn industry like really
interesting
like it i find the industry more
interesting than the actual movies
is that weird you know what i'm saying
no
weird you talk about movies about the
industry
yeah yeah it's just it's interesting
yeah it's an interesting industry
it's grift you know people that look
good or sometimes they don't look good
trying to make a buck in this industry
doing sex
yeah and you know that's going to be
some wild [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's it's not as weird as it was because
when you really look at porn now
most of it is just single women working
from their house
you don't need middlemen you don't need
a big expensive yeah it's not like back
in the old days when you actually had to
like make a film
yeah and back when you needed [ __ ]
even in the 80s and the 90s you needed
thousands of dollars worth of av
equipment sure you don't have that
anymore these girls could do it with
[ __ ] webcam
yeah they don't need any middlemen and
they just get all that [ __ ] profit
and of course you know the quality
in terms of aesthetics the quality of
the girls has increased a lot you know
good-looking girls do that but man when
i was a kid growing up in the early 80s
only ugly girls kind of did that [ __ ]
i mean kinda you know
the only ones that were good looking
were the real big names
and they they were in hollywood you know
what i mean yeah
so i remember some of them [ __ ]
back in the early 80s when i was [ __ ]
a little kid that had these [ __ ]
magazines called
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] like international
and [ __ ] stag
stag magazines and [ __ ] looking back
on it [ __ ] you can go back and go
look at some of that [ __ ] from the 80s
you know these
people have saved it you know what i
mean for posterity
you look at that girl man that's that's
like a crackhead
well the interesting thing is that if
you look at
porn from the 70s or 80s which i
actually like i said i find really
interesting or even if you look at porn
from like the 30s and 40s
i used to i have a dvd somewhere i don't
know where it's at but um
i think i bought it at the museum of sex
in new york actually
but um it just has like all these reels
of like porn from the 30s
yeah which was actually like way more
explicit than you would think if you
thought about the 1930s like they were
actually naked and they were actually
like [ __ ] and stuff it wasn't like
oh no an angle it wasn't like that so
especially france
well yeah the front the friendship the
french in the 20s and the 30s they were
actually doing beast porn and stuff
yeah yeah like i said there's nothing
new it's like you know
as far as porn goes but um yeah so i
find
all of that really interesting and it's
kind of like
one thing that kind of fascinated me was
like looking at some [ __ ] from the 70s
and how a lot of the girls like that
were even in playboy and stuff like that
they had like well obviously they had
bush because that was a thing they had
tan lines
yeah they had like [ __ ] yeah that's a
fetish thing though so that's
that's no no i mean they had like well
that was just like sexy
it was more like natural yeah like
nowadays everything's airbrushed
not an airbrush but then there's all the
enhancements that too
breast implants and so it's like nobody
so in in a way like
if you get like i don't you know there's
not like print magazines to the same
extent that there used to be but
nowadays like you see a picture of even
like a celebrity or something like that
like in a magazine
that's not what that person looks like
in real life they just stretch them out
it's been like completely like
photoshopped yeah they make their neck
longer they make their waist smaller
they make their thighs smaller they make
like everything you know i'm a graphic
designer i do photoshop all the time so
it's like i know
you know all the tricks all the [ __ ]
that they do it's like they smooth
everyone's skin they took all the
blemishes off they do this on the other
so it's like you get a picture that's
like not
so much like a person as like a a little
bit of a cartoon character
so it was interesting to see that like
in the 70s
they were a lot more forgiving of you
know
you know the chickens yeah the chick had
tan lines or she had like a blemish on
her ass or she had like you know
messy bush or whatever and it was just
kind of like everyone was like oh it's
still sexy you know what i mean
yeah the uh the threshold of
acceptability was a lot wider back then
because standards are lower
i guess you could say in a way yeah but
you know what's funny is that you can go
you know porn wasn't legal i don't think
in the united states until the 70s
maybe 60s oh might have been honestly
i think even when jon holmes was working
i think in a lot of places
porn movies were still it wasn't illegal
to watch them but it was illegal to make
them
yeah and then there was weird interstate
compacts about transporting them through
mail which meant you couldn't ship it
right so you couldn't ship it to other
states and so you had like there was all
these like work arounds there yeah yeah
so it was it was kind of a a weird time
um but you can go back and find you know
they had photography clubs what they
called them back then that was a cover
that was a cover for making porn yep and
then those dudes would [ __ ] set buy
sell and trade to [ __ ] with each other a
lot of it was going on in california
though
started started in the 50s and they had
some gorgeous women in the 50s
um doing that um you know
uh [ __ ] famous uh strippers is the
ones that were making them and they
all natural but very little russ meyers
you know
double g racks and [ __ ] looking good
you know what i mean nuggen
bell star and they were celebrities in
their own
right during those years maybe i have
i've somewhere i have a dvd with like
some uh
a little some video clips of bell star
actually yeah and
it wasn't really porn you know there
wasn't really sex going on in most of it
it
was just basically nude it was
titillation
yeah dancing and rolling around naked on
a blanket somewhere and then beach and
[ __ ]
but you know what i mean so they they
had good standards they know what a good
looking women
what a good level good-looking woman
looked like yes they couldn't get them
all the time
most of that [ __ ] was out in california
with the strippers because those uh
well i don't even think they called them
strippers back in the 50s i think they
were calling them uh
what they call them um i don't know
dancers entertainers well
[Laughter]
yeah but burlesque dancers type of deal
you know what i mean it was a way
they weren't totally nude they wore
pasties and [ __ ] yeah
you know cause can't chew a nipple for
christ right
and it was live shows and um back in
those days out in this
california and hollywood and they were
they were gorgeous you know they were
you know they had high standards then
it's just you know depends on where you
were
some of those girls were you know they
were genetic freaks by today's standards
well i've always thought that betty page
was
beautiful i she wasn't too shapely to me
i don't think she
well that's your opinion that's my
opinion i like very voluptuous you know
what i mean [ __ ]
and which is interesting because people
draw her very voluptuous but that's not
that's not but in real life she was
actually quite thin
yeah that's not how she looked you know
i thought her face was quite beautiful
yeah she had a beautiful face
yeah although i would say if i would of
course i would say you know
barbara eden was a lot better looking
yeah but she wasn't a porn star she's a
person
well i mean betty paige wasn't a porn
star yeah she did you know bdsm
stuff and yeah burlesque type stuff yeah
but um
you know the the burlesque stars that
are remembered today you could you can
find them out there you didn't just
google
you know [ __ ] those burlesque stars
of the 50s
yeah it was bell star uh lily saint seer
like
type of people and they were the same
kind of build that russ meyers was into
later on when he started making
movies you know yeah fix it and [ __ ]
like that yeah russ my i have uh russ
meyer's
uh biography back there and you know it
wasn't most of those and then what was
said
the japanese girl what was the name
something or sentence satana
yeah joey zoe satana yeah she looked
great too
she [ __ ] and i think she was all
natural i think i think most of them
were some of them had
you know silicone infusion and stuff but
most of them weren't
most of them were bona fide genetic
freaks you know
big boob girls you know yeah you did
have a few of those back in the day
yeah they rose to the top back then yeah
because of the rarity
well and like i said i think that's kind
of you know coming back to the topic a
little bit i think that's kind of what
happened with john holmes yeah
genetic freak yeah yes i mean if you're
if you're coming at it from that
point of view he was kind of like he was
born in this nowhere town
um he didn't really have a lot of skills
um as far as work but yeah he had a 13
14 inch dick yeah
and um it's it's weird because
like the town he was born like he was
born in some little town he had married
he had done all this other stuff
and then i guess he got discovered by a
photographer who saw him and was like
hey can we take some naked pictures of
you
because he wasn't you know he wasn't a
bad looking dude but he wasn't like
anything that would turn your head like
in the street or anything like that
he was just like an average looking kind
of scrawny dude
but when they found out how big his dick
was
they everybody wanted to take pictures
of it and
from that um he got like a lot of he got
attention from like porn producers that
were like yeah we need to put you in
porn it doesn't even matter what you
look like you just have like this
massive dick
so he basically because he was married
at the time like i said his wife's name
was uh sharon
who was played by elisa kudrow in the
movie wonderland if you were curious
and she he was basically like this i
discovered what i want to do with my
life
i'm going to do porn and he basically
justified it because she was like oh so
you want to be a horror that's what you
want to do now
and he was kind of like well just think
of it as me being a carpenter
and my dick is my tool that's basically
like how he justified it too and she's
like
not buying it but okay but yeah so he
went off and
i mean him and his wife became estranged
like uh obviously for obvious reasons
and as many people in the comments have
pointed out john holmes was
actually a giant piece of [ __ ] because
not only
um did he like it would have been fine
like again not great
that he was just kind of like told his
wife hey i'm going to be in porn i don't
care what you
say about it you know that's
okay that's forgivable maybe but then
like later he became like a total coke
head um he allegedly
participated in these wonderland murders
which we were talking about
and also after his uh career had started
to go south because of the cocaine
addiction because he couldn't get it up
anymore
um and he got aids that's right
and because everyone in la knew that he
got aids
because of the rumor mill and so no one
would hire him anymore
so he basically went overseas to italy
to be in porn movies and didn't tell
anyone
gave everybody aids and then he was in
like a bunch of movies over there and
like
with i don't know if anybody got aids
because of him
but he for sure knew that he had it and
went over there
and so yeah not forgivable
that is not forgivable he was a giant
piece of [ __ ]
it's weird because like i said when i
was in new york city
uh several years ago probably 2008 2009
i think it was
and i went to the museum of sex there
and i think they had
they had some like movies of john holm
so they had like a [ __ ]
a thing about john holmes just because
he's kind of like one of the best known
porn stars in the us and like they had
that kind of thing
and i guess when i saw that i didn't
really know like what
um a [ __ ] he was you know what i mean
so kind of reading about this crime has
really like
put a whole new i got a whole new
perspective on the dude you know what i
mean because all i knew before oh he's a
famous
he was a famous porn star with a huge
giant dick that's pretty much all i knew
i didn't know that he was involved with
this [ __ ] i didn't know about the aids
thing i didn't know about any of that
so the l.a scene back in that you know
there's a lot of bad [ __ ] going on in it
i mean yeah not only were they making
movie time you know not just in
hollywood you know
where they're just making movies they
were also doing a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
up [ __ ] to each other and stealing [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know somebody mentioned you
know bob crane and the other john
carpenter oh yeah they were doing
[ __ ] weird [ __ ]
too you know what i mean it was it was a
bad place
you know not everybody in it was bad but
a lot of them were
well i kind of feel like if you were
there long enough you would kind of get
sucked into it you know everyone was
kind of desperate everyone was kind of
yeah desperate for the next [ __ ]
score in terms of
making money and then they were buying
drugs and there was a lot of [ __ ]
weird sex and [ __ ] going around and they
were pimping themselves out
you know this is a bad scene and oh also
i forgot to mention too that john holmes
also used to pimp out his girlfriend
sounds about right yeah much to her
chagrin yeah i think anything about it
i think she wrote a book later okay well
he got in he got
in with her when she was much younger
like they do
because you know right grooming he just
told her it was all just free love
behind her back that's what
i mean and in the movie wonderland they
kind of show that
he took this poor girl who i think was
in her 20s like at this point but i
think he got together with her when she
was like 15 or 16
so yeah just saying well there's a lot
there was always a lot of poverty in
california
yeah and like you know everyone's kind
of like trying to get drugs i get that
they're all trying to move up in life
one thing you know i'm from california
from [ __ ] originally from
from carson you know which is right
there near long beach
california was always a place where
you'd have [ __ ] incredible riches
and then a lot of poverty right next to
it and anytime you have that when you
have a dichotomy
of a lot of wealth and poverty yeah side
by side
yeah that's never a good thing yeah the
rich guys go on there and [ __ ] abuse
all the [ __ ] poor girls
yeah because they didn't really they
don't have much of a choice really
yeah no defenses you know what i mean
what are you gonna do you're like oh
don't you want to move up in life
well come over here and blow him blow
that one and blow this and yeah
yeah that's essentially what well that's
kind of what john holmes was doing
it's like he was saying to his
girlfriend hey if you
[ __ ] this rich guy he'll give us all
this money and we can buy drugs with it
right yeah and she was like i'd rather
not and he's like and then he would beat
the [ __ ] out of her right so he was also
he beat his girlfriend up also yeah so
you know special it's called putting the
pimp hands down
that's some may call it that
yeah it's a process some may call it
putting the pimp
hand down that's how they say it i i
like the academic way that you say that
well yeah
back in mary old england
you don't think they had a pimp hand in
england everyone's got a pimple
everyone's got a pen pad
i heard i heard ireland had one of the
biggest of all pam pants
wait who was that i don't know let me
make [ __ ] up all right i was gonna say
that
that seemed random yeah i'm just
thinking like back
in the honky motherland then with their
[ __ ]
yeah with their chile lays with the
chile and the little [ __ ] buckles on
the shoes putting the [ __ ] pimp hand
down on a [ __ ]
you will make us money please tell me
trying to move up and then the dude's
got a corset on and he like you know
[ __ ] in a walking stick and [ __ ] you
know what i mean
more dudes should wear corsets i feel
yeah what were those dudes called
dandy's
dandies that's right dandy's dandy's and
there's always a poor dude trying
to [ __ ] if i have to wear a corset to
go out yeah they put a corset on
underneath their yellows to make them
look more
make them look more streamlined you know
what i mean i'm rearranging my
organs so i can look better yeah yeah
someone else can do back
in ye old honky motherland please tell
me
that in ireland chileli is um
slang for penis i don't know is it
i've never heard that well it's gnarled
up it's gnarled up and naughty and
that's what i mean but i feel like it's
got a little
it's gotta be though i don't know i want
my own
having so much irish blood in me being
southern and [ __ ]
i have to get a shelly i'm going to
carry around shirley
just to beat a motherfucker's ass with
one day go out to the club and i just
i'm not even a punch at anybody i'm just
going to beat him with a shillelagh
like back in the old days
yeah well that again ties back to these
persons
because they were bludgeoning you might
actually get off you know i mean they
might drop charges
well depending on wait wait wait hold on
wait you used to
okay go ahead go ahead you're good
you're good
go ahead okay lady that's all case
dismissed
your honor hey he used the chile you
know
like back in the hockey motherland
everyone's like oh fair enough yeah
oh okay all right again it's legit
that's og [ __ ]
and you guys know my address if you guys
from back in in the home in the monk
honking motherland the monkey heather
lynch as the
[Laughter]
with pride in orlando
the old part of the spanish empire
yeah this is spanish empire territory i
will [ __ ] carve out a new niche
[ __ ] pudding yeah this is florida's
totally totally spanish
the spanish and seminole it is spanish
and seminole indians but
i'm going to colonize the [ __ ] out of
this [ __ ] with a [ __ ] lately in
my right hand [ __ ] it right man [ __ ]
have a little bit of your pimp head with
his shoulders
and [ __ ] have my derby on and [ __ ]
have that [ __ ] [ __ ] cocked up on the
side of my head like that
[ __ ] right i'm gonna [ __ ] put the
o on the end of my uh on the beginning
of my name oh ross
or ross i would probably an o on it
beginning
anyway at one time i will give you a
hundred dollars
five hundred dollars yeah if you will
wear a leprechaun
outfit [ __ ] i got a leprechaun i gotta i
wear that [ __ ] 24 7.
okay maybe not 500 maybe 250 200. i
[ __ ] buy
yeah little shorts and stuff and little
[ __ ] yeah
yeah box of lucky charms yeah grow my
beard out
little red you don't have red hair like
me though yeah my dad does though
yeah yeah i know i don't know if people
know but i'm not my dad
i'm actually a natural yeah i'm also a
natural ginger
i just dyed this color because it's
probably gray at this point because
you've all been talking about
but yeah so man my drink's empty you
need to do something about that
i'll finish it you sit here talking
about this yeah
michael shaffer said what about gluing
fur to your feet and you could be a
hobbit
you could be a hobbit
why am i getting okay
all right have we even started talking
about the crime yet no hold on
you really should they're talking about
being [ __ ] dressed up like a
leprechaun
see i told you i will give you 250
dollars i'll give you 250
if you do it buy a leprechaun outfit
get the hat get the wig you can have a
shillelai if you want i'm gonna make it
i'm gonna make this a
drink aaron says i do miss the halloween
wig
well i yeah i kind of like that wig
actually i don't know why man i got all
these i got all these [ __ ] teddy
pictures after that
women were sending me pictures of their
breastuses after i wore the wig
really said it looked just like [ __ ]
robert plant
i'm [ __ ] weird i was gonna say what
you didn't tell me
no one's like oh man you're willy wonka
hair it gets me hot
tila says he needs a gold tooth too he
really does
i do like that halloween wig actually i
still have it i'll wear it just
at random like i said that's actually
pretty close to my natural hair color
but i don't know what my natural hair
color is anymore because
i've been dyeing it black for so long
it's just so much easier
all right so let's talk about
the wonderland murders um also sometimes
called the
four on the floor murders which seems a
little
dismissive i guess i don't know or the
laurel canyon murders which is a little
bit of a boring name
so this is a quadruple homicide although
it was actually
uh intended to be five people that were
murdered except the fifth one
survived which they didn't think that
she would
um but yeah so it's four people took
place in july
of 1981. now the victims
um were all members of
well they were either members of this
drug gang in la which is called the
wonderland gang at the time just
wonderland because that was like the
name of the street that the um house
that they
dealt out of was on um but
one of the people was like well actually
three of them were in the gang two of
them were like just like a
dru like gang adjacent so they weren't
like actually gang members i guess if
you want to call it a gang
so i think that's kind of the reason why
thank you
that's kind of the reason why it's not
um given the same
i guess it's not given the same cachet
maybe if that's the right word to use
as like the manson family murders
because
i mean the manson family murders
obviously like all the victims are just
like innocent people like these people
just like busted in their house at
random and just like
you know brutally murdered all these
people the wonderland murders were kind
of a little bit different because
you know the people that were victims
and i'm not saying they necessarily
deserved what happened to them
but um the people that were murdered
were not
innocent victims let's just say that um
the fact that they were targeted
was because of some [ __ ] that had
happened like a couple days
prior to the murders like it was like a
retaliation type of [ __ ]
so that's what we're uh you know going
to
so let's talk a little bit about before
we get into the murders
let's talk a little bit about the
wonderland gang
itself so basically this is a group of
drug dealers um who were very
kind of high up in the whole cocaine
trade in the late 1970s and early 1980s
in los angeles
now the home base of the gang
was at this like townhouse on wonderland
avenue
in uh laurel canyon uh in la
and so the this house
and it's interesting because you know
the person that recommended that we do
this
uh case has said that they've been to
this particular house or they've seen it
i guess this house is one that is kind
of like a magnet for ghost hunters just
because people you dropped your glasses
there
um it's a magnet for i could take care
of my glasses
well you don't need to tell me that i
dropped him i saw him
i saw him fall jenny i saw him fall
okay i got this under control mr left
the stove on mister left the coffee pot
on all night hey man i'm juggling a
bunch of [ __ ] it was
i'm juggling a bunch of [ __ ]
it does i'm just teasing him yeah but
yeah so
um yeah so they said they'd been to this
house it's like it's
kind of like a townhouse right and i
guess
it's one of those places where everybody
that wanted to go get cocaine
mainly um or heroin or whatever that's
where all the dealers are hanging would
go to this place
and that's where you would go to score
and it had been like that for several
years that's kind of where all the gang
members
hung out so even though they were kind
of like all up in the cocaine trade that
was like
i think as far as i can determine the
wonderland gang
were actually um kind of the main go-to
people for like the cocaine trade
in that time period in la which is
saying something
i suppose um so
interestingly though even like a bunch
of their members were actually heroin
addicts
not cocaine addicts so i don't know i
don't know if they were so much selling
the heroin as like just
they were doing it themselves and then
selling the cocaine i don't know but
yeah so that's kind of the thing
so uh as i said the house is still there
it's at 8763 wonderland avenue
in laurel canyon los angeles and it's
still there like i said a lot of ghost
hunters go there because
all these people got murdered there and
it's supposedly [ __ ]
so it's two bedrooms now the house was
actually
rented at the time by joy
miller joy miller
um she was the girlfriend of this
dude billy deverell and he was also a
member of the gang
now joy miller i guess she had been kind
of like a successful person but she got
breast cancer
and had to have a double mastectomy i
think and like so she was uh
and also a heroin addict and she kind of
so she kind of like
fell into drug addiction later on in her
life
so i guess that she just kind of i don't
know if she did it willingly or just
kind of happened or whatever but so she
was
you know holding the lease on this house
and like letting all these people hang
out there
like as you know drug dens kind of like
do
so um at this stage there was this dude
named david lind
now he was originally from sacramento
now the summer of 1981 like prior to the
murders occurring
um ron lonius who was kind of one of the
highest members of the gang and we'll
kind of get
more into their backstories in a little
bit he actually called david lind
because they had known each other in
prison
and he was like hey we got like all this
cocaine distribution business down here
we need some help
so just like it's like the drug addicts
linkedin
i suppose so they're all kind of like
hey come down here and help us
deal drugs you know like you do so
that's what happened so david lynn comes
down and uh they're all staying at the
same house
now john holmes um was kind of a
peripheral he wasn't
in the gang but he was like a peripheral
member
because he would hang out at this house
all the time now like i said i don't
know if a lot of people know
because john holmes like i said very
famous um
he was in a whole bunch of
porn films in the 70s and early 80s
as a private investigator character
called johnny wadd
yes sounds familiar can we please come
up with a better name
yeah yeah sounds familiar names are so
tough i remember that name
yeah well he was in like what like a
thousand movies like he was in like a
ridiculous
john holmes yeah okay that was his
character that was his character name
and honestly it was kind of like well
like i said if you've seen boogie nights
yeah you know where they try to like
we're jerk digglers they're like we're
gonna make you into like a super secret
spy like a james bond except a porn
version yeah
that was what they were that's what they
were doing like with john holmes
like i said john holmes was kind of this
just scrawny
like dude with sort of like a white man
afro this horrible smoked some big huge
sunglasses that you have back in the day
he was [ __ ] he was but he had a giant
dick he was scuzzy looking he looked he
looked
from what i remember he was pretty
scuzzy look it's kind of like a like a
tall thin ron jeremy
that's you know i mean about that level
i know even though ron jeremy when he
was young was good looking
he was actually in play girl and [ __ ] he
got fat though later i don't know what
[ __ ] happened to him
but uh i don't think ro jeremy was ever
good looking no he was when he was young
he was good-looking he was kind of
[ __ ] muscular muscular guy he looked
a lot like burt reynolds
burt reynolds wasn't good looking either
that's not what i meant no i know but he
had that same hair and that same
mustache the handlebar mustache you know
hey if you don't believe me there's
[ __ ] pictures to prove it you know
what i mean if i can
go look no i know i'm just well i guess
he's just not my type
when ron de jeremy was [ __ ] in his
prime he was a respectable
looking guy um what you're saying
i mean he looks looked like [ __ ] by the
time i was [ __ ] 18 but
well the thing the interesting thing
about it is there's all the porn it
looked like a [ __ ] hedgehog having
sex with these beautiful women
yeah but like as well the thing about
porn though
even in the 70s was that no one was
going to see i mean porn is largely
marketed toward men
and i think even nowadays like mostly
men watch that stuff
so it's kind of because women usually
will read erotica like a lot of women
watch porn too but it's kind of like a
different
like demographic so i feel like in the
70s
you know since porn was aimed toward men
it didn't really matter
what the dudes looked like it just
mattered what the women looked like
you know what i'm saying like the dude
could be just like okay looking or just
average looking or whatever because the
dude wasn't looking at that dude unless
it was gay porn that's a whole other
thing
but i feel like in straight porn it
didn't really matter as much but
well because like i said john holmes
when he first started out he was first
started out
um being in like erotic photographs like
he got discovered by somebody because
they just saw him and i
i don't know like how it's happened
exactly but he was just
um he someone saw his dick somewhere and
like some photographer was like hey you
have a giant dick so i'm gonna like take
some erotic photographs of you
and from that he like parlayed that into
a film career
and a lot of the porn producers at the
time because there were a lot of
interviews with them on this this
documentary that i saw
and they were talking about they're like
well john holmes comes in
like because he wants to be in porn
movies suddenly because he's decided
that he's found his calling
and they're like to look at him they're
like he wasn't good looking he was just
like this scrawny
like whatever but then like he takes his
pants off just like dirk tiggler did in
boogie nights and everyone's like okay
you're hired you know what i mean
there's a great scene on that
where where um burt reynolds is playing
the [ __ ] porn director says uh
this is a dirk uh you know can can i see
it and the
guy pulled it out and it was kind of
like that scene from pulp fiction where
they opened the briefcase and the
[ __ ] girl right
he's [ __ ] that's pretty well
according to
the interviews that i saw that's kind of
what it was like
were they like you see this dude like
walking in the office who just looks
like this scrawny
70s looking dude and they're just like
yeah no thanks and then he's like hey
check this out and they're just like oh
all right what was funny about right
about that
i see what you do i see what you're
laying down it's funny in that movie
though it's like
you got burt reynolds [ __ ] [ __ ]
meat gazing on this [ __ ] just
gazing and he gets lost in it for a
second
it's like he's caught like he's going
out of body a little bit
yeah and then he goes thank you thank
you
burt reynolds is so good in that movie i
and like i said that it seemed like that
wasn't
that much of an exaggeration you know
what i mean
well because they could just see dollar
signs like ching
i don't know because i mean it's having
a 13 or 14 inch dick that's like pretty
uh that's pretty freakish [ __ ]
burt reynolds character that was like he
had seen some kind of [ __ ] miracle
right thank you i appreciate the thank
you very much
thank you for showing me that yeah she
was hilarious that's a great move you
guys need to see it it is really great
yeah i love that movie i saw that in the
theater when it came out it came out in
1997 i know that was a long time ago
yeah
but yeah i saw in the theater and i've
seen it like many times since then
um so yeah so basically
john holmes like i said he wasn't a
member of the gang he wasn't a drug
dealer necessarily but
as time went on he became
like an insatiable like coke fiend he
was freebasing and everything
so he was b he would like hang out at
this house like either buying drugs or
trying to like scrounge them off of
people because after a while like he was
obviously like running out of money and
doing [ __ ] like that
somebody said um up there that he did
gay porn too he did actually like later
on
like after because of his cocaine
addiction um he became
impotent um and so a lot of porn
producers
in la would not work with him anymore
and after a while he tried to make a
comeback by doing like some gay porn and
i think he did like do a bunch of gay
porn
type of movies uh later on in his career
just because he couldn't but he had done
like a whole bunch like prior to that
but it does really seem like his career
kind of
really tanked because a lot of the
producers that they interviewed for this
documentary that i saw
were talking about after a while they're
like he would show up on set and he
would just like look like crap
um and then he'd be like uh hey i have
to like go somewhere
for a little bit like you know what i
mean and he was just like really
unreliable and he was just like
he couldn't get it up and like all this
other kind of stuff so they like kind of
got sick of working with him
but yeah so like i said he wasn't in the
gang but he was kind of like
tangentially he would like hang out at
this house all the time
and he knew like all of these uh kind of
people
so uh this gang the wonderland gang
not only like drug dealing was their
main thing but they also
did um you know uh they would break in
to people's houses they would steal
stuff they would do like home invasions
stuff like that usually on other drug
dealers but not always
um and the fact that they
um did a particular home invasion on a
particularly um
inadvisable target was probably the
reason that they all got themselves
killed so let's talk about
like before we get into that let's talk
about like each of the members
particularly like and these
most of these people did end up getting
killed spoiler alert in the wonderland
murders so kind of the i guess he's like
the head of the gang sort of there's
this guy named
ron lonnius now he was um
in the air force he was a veteran from
the vietnam
era now he had actually been
dishonorably discharged from the air
force
because he had been smuggling heroin
back from vietnam inside the bodies
of dead u.s soldiers so
we're not talking about a real quality
person
is is what i'm saying now
also uh when he was killed in the
wonderland murders
um lapd said that they had 27
open homicide cases that they think that
ron lonius had allegedly
committed so not only was he smuggling
drugs back
in dead soldiers bodies
but also he was allegedly
responsible for at least 27 murders or
at least they suspected him of
committing 27 murders
so he had actually been arrested before
um
there was a murder in 1973 which was
he supposedly killed like a
a police drug informant now
there was this whole thing that was like
um a guy that had like [ __ ] he was
going to
um be a witness for the prosecution
and then he got killed in a shootout
which was not related to the initial
thing
and then that whole situation resulted
in the
charges against ron lonnie's being
dropped so he didn't get in trouble for
that even though they're pretty sure
that he did it
okay um oh okay puka's outside
better be good yeah she better be i'll
go check on her a little bit okay i
can't believe it's only six o'clock at
night yeah
we're an hour into it we're an hour into
the hour and 20 minutes
okay so so yeah
um so the same year though like he got
off with the murder charge
but he was um convicted of smuggling
heroin and cocaine
over the u.s mexico border
he got an eight year sentence but he
only ended up sending uh
serving three years um you missed it but
i was saying this
main guy like one of the dudes that got
killed in the wonderland murders
um was i thought you would find this
interesting
he was a in the air force in vietnam
and he was convicted or was at least um
suspected of smuggling heroin back into
the country in the bodies of u.s
soldiers that were coming back from
vietnam
that'd be an easy way to do it so yeah
also suspected of 27 murders yeah he was
suspected of 27
yeah damn like i said not a not a
quality individual we're talking about
like i said so maybe that's why maybe
that's why this doesn't get the same
uh attention as like the manson murders
because
the people that got killed i'm not
saying people deserve to get murdered
i'm just saying that the people that got
killed were not great people
so it's kind of like everyone was like
no one no one really cares a lot match i
don't know
um so yeah romlanius was actually
described
by a particular police officer that
interviewed him as quote
one of the coldest people i've ever met
and i love this quote i found this on
wikipedia this other officer said
when he heard that ron lanie had been
murdered in the wonderland murders
he said and i quote i suppose they won't
be needing many
pallbearers and the dude was like well
what do you mean he's like
a trash can only has two handles oh
i was like oh oh
get some [ __ ] ointment for that burn
that's pretty good line i'm gonna have
to remember that
somehow
so yeah so he had a wife named uh susan
murphy
who was also present at the time so
here's this other guy billy deverell now
this was the boyfriend of joy miller the
woman that owned the or she didn't own
it but she leased the townhouse that
they all
were murdered and they all stayed at so
uh billy deverell was kind of
um ron lonnie's like second in command i
guess you could say
now this dude not so much of a [ __ ]
as ron was i guess most people described
him as like he was pretty much okay like
he was a decent guy
um he actually just kind of got into the
drugs because it was like an easy way to
make money he wasn't like a particularly
like
psychopathic kind of [ __ ] or anything
like that
um and he also seemed to have something
of a conscience
about like he kept wanting to get out of
it like he was a drug addict also
um so he had kind of gotten sucked into
that lifestyle and he
seemed to like feel bad about it and he
did seem to have like regrets about his
actions or what have you i'm having
problems with power here
i got to get an extension cord wrong
okay
so um so this guy he had actually had a
job at some point i don't know if he had
a job at the time that uh
all of this [ __ ] happened but he was uh
he did he was an overhead crane operator
um but he was also a heroin addict and
he had been arrested
13 times in relation to his heroin
addiction
and so this was kind of one of the
reasons that he couldn't get away from
the gang even though
he reportedly was not super into it and
was like trying to get
like turn his life around um
so yeah so as i said he was like a
really bad drug addict and it's kind of
in that way it's kind of sad now david
lind
um who this was interesting because in
the movie wonderland which i just
watched a couple days ago
this character was played by dylan
mcdermott
who i didn't recognize at first because
they made him look like
your standard like scuzzy biker type of
dude
and i'm like watching him while i'm
watching him talk and i'm looking at his
face i'm like oh my god that's dylan
mcdermott because usually i don't know
like he usually doesn't play
roles like that i guess or i haven't
seen him play roles like that so i
didn't recognize him at first but he's
played by um
dylan mcdermott in the 2003 movie so
this dude
also kind of a piece of [ __ ] gotta admit
um
he was a biker which is fine but he was
also a heroin addict
and he was also in the aryan brotherhood
now he and ron lonnius had met when they
were both in
prison so in 1981
ron lonnius had apparently said hey
we're doing all this like [ __ ]
drug business down here like why don't
you and your girlfriend come down here
and help us out
so that's basically what david lind did
now he had been david lind at this stage
in 1981
had been incarcerated many times on
various charges burglary forgery assault
and assault with the intent to commit
rape so that's fun
um now this guy like i said
he kind of interestingly in the movie
wonderland
they kind of portray david lind at first
as almost a sympathetic character
because it's almost kind of like
his narrative versus john holmes's
narrative is kind of how they
um framed the movie so they almost kind
of make david lin
seem like a sympathetic character at
first
and then as the story goes on he gets
like
less and less credible which i thought
was like a really interesting narrative
choice it's a really good movie like i
said it's it's on to be if you want to
watch it
and it's actually pretty um
accurate to the facts of the case and
does a pretty good job
of because like i said this
this murder is technically considered
unsolved
just because the people that they think
did it were not convicted
so they do a good job of like kind of
walking that tightrope between saying
look we pretty much know what happened
but these are like the two versions of
what happened but they're pretty similar
they're pretty similar and uh you know
without
saying that anybody did it like
definitively you know what i'm saying so
they did a good job of doing that
so as i said david lind i don't think
they mentioned that he was in the aryan
brother
brotherhood of the movie although his
tattoos might have showed that i didn't
really
look but yeah so there was that whole
thing now there was this other guy
in it named tracy mccourt this guy i
don't even remember if they
portrayed him in the movie or not but he
was just basically like the getaway
driver
he was actually supposed to allegedly
have um participated in the crime but
for whatever reason
uh ron lonius didn't want him to come in
the house i don't know if he'd like
[ __ ] up or something so he's just like
well you just have to drive the getaway
car and like stay out there and shut up
so that was kind of that whole thing um
and like i said i mentioned joy miller
before she was the girlfriend of billy
deveral she was the one that owned the
lease on the
house where it all happened um she was
actually
um the billy deveral was actually her
second she had been married before
to like some high up attorney like in
beverly hills or whatever and she had a
couple kids that were grown
um she was actually um had sort of
become
she was like a normal person i guess and
then she had kind of
gotten sucked into this whole drug thing
and she had breast cancer and got her
breast
removed or whatever so there was also
a couple of other people susan lonius
who was ron's wife
um she was the only
person to survive the wonderland murders
even though
it seemed like it was the intent to kill
her i will talk about that a little bit
later
um and there was another woman there
named barbara richardson that was david
lynn's girlfriend she was 22 at the time
known as butterfly because of one of her
tattoos
um now both her and david lind were
suspected to be police informants
although i don't think that that's ever
been
particularly uh you know established but
they were just like rumored to have been
police informants so
now the wonderland murders allegedly
occurred
as a retaliation a retaliation for what
you may ask
because these people decided
that they were going to rob
a dude named eddie nash
now at the time eddie nash
was one of the best-known gangsters and
also nightclub owners in the la area he
owned the kitkat
strip club he owned like several he
owned gay clubs he owned like clubs that
were uh geared toward african americans
he gave he
like owned all these clubs in the area
he was kind of like
one of the main dudes that was kind of
like the nightlife dude everyone knew he
was a gangster but it was kind of like
it's kind of like one of those things
where everybody knows that he's like up
to all this illegal [ __ ] but they
couldn't really like
you know pin him down on anything and
they couldn't really do anything about
it because he had so much money and like
cache and power in the area so
it was kind of one of those situations
now
what ended up happening
they're talking about your mst3 k
[ __ ] collection box underneath the
i have so many of them yeah she got a
[ __ ] ton
mst is probably one of my favorite
things ever it's good but you know i'm
kind of she knows all the references i
only know like [ __ ] maybe one third
of them
i really only start laughing to me
that's some nerdy [ __ ]
it is funny but i own minorities
it doesn't really [ __ ] get funny
until they start singing
when because i have more of a musical
sense of humor
they'll start singing to some kind of
theme song to something
and it'll be in the context that i start
[ __ ] busting up but the rest of that
[ __ ]
you have to be [ __ ] you have to
understand you have to be like an
english lit or [ __ ] you have to
read a lot of stuff and read a lot of
people well that's what i was like
well the thing the thing that i always
liked about mst classic
literature and classic movies and [ __ ]
you know what i mean well it's not just
that though i liked that
they could like one second they can make
a joke about like [ __ ]
escalus or so like some [ __ ] ancient
greek [ __ ] and then like the next second
they can make like a fart joke yeah like
it's very like high brow low brow and i
like that
that they just like don't even make a
distinction yeah like i really like that
about it
um i liked those live shows that we saw
for the rift tracks
yeah live rip tracks i mean birdemic was
one of them
was one of the best ones i i had a
headache from like my i had a headache
and a face ache from laughing so much i
thought
live burdemic and also the live [ __ ]
manos hands of fate i was just [ __ ]
laughing that whole [ __ ]
i didn't think [ __ ] i didn't i didn't
like um the one that i didn't like was
uh starship troopers
i didn't think that one was that funny
because i like that movie
you know a lot i like that movie i'm
just saying you know
everybody busting on it but that's what
they do
though yeah but i like you know i don't
think it's a bad movie right but it's
got to be a bad movie for me to really
enjoy it
yeah that's true you know but they've
done good movies too yeah
you can always find something to like
jokes
when the movie is very bad like mano's
hands of fate is
[ __ ] terrible it's so terrible it
almost comes back
and it's almost sublime it horks itself
in the
in the air and you're like no it's kind
of good
it's so bad that it's good there's
something about manos that i actually
really like
there's a there's like a weird like
creepy atmosphere about it
and and burdemic there's something about
the tone of [ __ ] burdemic that is
so corporate cheap and flimsy
that i started to enjoy burdemic
especially when you got people busting
on it
i [ __ ] love burden the thing that i
love about birdemic and actually about
all that dudes and movies
that dude does not know anything about
men and women he doesn't well
yeah the answer and well the thing about
it is that he seems like such a nice man
and he seems like so genuine and
everything but
also i suspect that he might be an alien
in a skin suit yeah because
he really doesn't seem to know how real
people talk or real people interact
or anything about anything and i hate to
like [ __ ] on him because he seems like a
nice man
but it's like watch burdemic he's old
he's a he's an old so weird he's an old
asian guy
it's so weird and having lived in korea
you know what i mean a [ __ ]
the korean i you know i really liked
korea but i understand the limitations
of korea and its culture it's a lot
better than it
now than it was but the guy who made
birdemic
he thinks that dating between white
people is stalking
is stalking all right one that that's
why guys get
women by stalking them that's what he
actually thinks
and the relationship is almost entirely
comprised of
her sitting on your lap
it's so weird yeah it's straddling you
facing it that that's
that's that's he's totally into that
that was that whatever he shows a white
couple
it's the dudes sitting there and the
woman straddling him
and they're not even moving they're not
even moving and it's just like that's
dating
it's so strange that's dating in his
mind is he vietnamese was he vietnamese
in origin it was some weird he might be
vietnamese i think he's vietnamese
but he's misunderstanding the western
relationship
between between men and women i i don't
even know if it's like a cultural issue
i think it's just like a person issue i
think like
he doesn't have well it's a it it's it's
everything all rolled into
because i've seen other vehicles that
were completely normal
we're products of our culture and
[ __ ] everybody not only has a
regional culture from their heritage
it's also the family culture that they
come from that area you know what i mean
like when i was in korea not all koreans
were the same all right well obviously
they're just not
but they all have the same culture they
do yeah it's like well
it's the thing about the culture that
you come from gives you like a series of
parameters like but there's always
people that are like
and in those clubs you know and i mean
some of those girls that weren't working
in those clubs they were just hanging
out and having fun
they were actually very subversive for
korean culture
1990 91 they were very subversive
they were like they were like korea's
version of a punk rocker
or korea's version of a goth girl or
something
they just were they weren't the normal
korean girl yeah you know
normal korean girls didn't like
foreigners they didn't go to clubs
they didn't like any of that music they
liked korean stuff
so it's just which like i said fair
enough yeah yeah
it's just the way [ __ ] is all right well
um to me
honestly the weirdest thing about uh
what's it god damn it what's his name
james nyan nyan
right yeah i can't remember what his
name is
he made like um a couple of other and
rifftrax has done them as well
i can't remember what the name of that
one was we watched the other day but the
thing that's
interesting to me about burdemic not so
much like the shitty special effects or
like the weird stalking or whatever
the weirdest thing to me was like the
corporate
dick sucking yeah that was very very
weird he must have had something like
what like why did he think solar panels
that was so interesting that you would
want to watch a bunch of like just
generic stuff about solar panels white
people
in a board room talking about hey
we made our sales quota this month it's
like nobody wants to go to those
meetings in real life why would i want
to watch a movie the movie was
a text [ __ ] about a movie was a tax show
or some
company it is not interesting everyone
hates what are the bombs they try to win
what about the movies from that dude you
know his name i don't know his name but
you know who i'm gonna talk about
the dude who constantly portrays himself
as an alien jesus computer specialist
that comes down to save the earth
what the dude that i'm going to [ __ ]
let me say it again
well i heard you the first time i just
didn't know where you're talking
he's made several films and he's always
this savior figure
and oh right right he comes down and
he's a genius at whatever he does
i know what you're talking about that
about
did a bunch of watch check case set
i love that dude i need to buy some of
his books also i didn't know that they
made british people that good
badger have you seen [ __ ] casey cinema
johnny
in the uk there's cool people there's
lots of cool people i hope so i hope so
i hope there's more of them there's lots
of cool people over there okay
i probably met more cool people over
there than i've met over here he's from
the hood though i got a feeling he's
from the hood
well it's not really the same the hood
is not the same over there
it's it's not really this i like him i
thought i thought he was hilarious
well like i said it's every time i watch
one of his videos because he doesn't um
post as much as he used to because like
he's been going like a really long time
but i guess he kind of got sick of it
so he puts up a movie every now and then
um
but he's also a writer and so i feel
like every time i watch the video i'm
like goddammit i need to like
buy some of his books see they know what
i'm talking about
alien jesus computer specialist the
other guy go oh brad
something what the [ __ ] is that dude's
name
like i said [ __ ] case cinema like he's
done like a bunch of his movies he makes
movies yeah he is always he's always
like the same
thing the main he's always the main
character and he's always some kind of
superhuman
he's either an alien he's a jesus-like
alien that comes down and he knows
everything about computers and he's
trying to save the world
and all the women love him of course in
the in these movies and you look at the
dude you're like
what you know come on
see this is what they mean when ever
okay
so like every writer [ __ ] uh
you know [ __ ] that you go into
they always tell you this is a big
phrase in writing and screenwriting
any kind of writing kill your darlings
don't write yourself into [ __ ]
one two don't write your
[ __ ] fantasy image unless it's fanfic
that's fine but if you're writing like a
movie or something like that
don't write it so that like you
are clearly the main character yeah and
you can just do
everything awesome without having to
learn how to do everything
it's like you're always like you get all
the ladies yeah
you know how to do everything
immediately yeah you know what it's it's
just
very very because you you end up it's
very transparent
it's what it ends up being the dudes
sucking your own dick you mean he's
sucking your own dick on [ __ ]
camera that's what you're doing i mean
you're essentially you're
you're like you're putting yourself in
the center of the [ __ ] right
you're like bella in twilight you're a
mary sue
at this stage you like you're the best
at everything
yeah you don't have to learn to do
anything you don't have to struggle
you don't have to do anything nobody
wants to read that [ __ ] okay
keep it like i said keep it on your fan
fiction forum that's fine no one's going
to complain about that
but if you're going to like publish a
book about it
keep your [ __ ] out of it man keep your
[ __ ] up that [ __ ] was hilarious
i'm just saying keep your [ __ ] out of it
so i so i'm wondering
about the dude and like i said i hate to
[ __ ] on the dude
yeah the the guy that did uh burdemic
and several
words also that's it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's his name thank you
thank you very much that's who we're
talking we're gonna give you credit for
that
it's alex rivera alex you got her a neil
breen that's right i didn't
like i knew who you were talking about
but i couldn't remember his name yeah
how did you come up with that alex
he must have seen it well a lot of
people know that dude's movies i just
couldn't
dude right there man okay
although you know what was funny i gotta
say i enjoyed the rift tracks of that
which one the neil breen movies yeah
wasn't it wasn't it the
tracks or was that or was that [ __ ] case
cinema well [ __ ] casey did
he did it too he's done several news
yeah he's done several
nail groom movies that dude there man
he said he searched it on youtube it was
a tip of my time yeah it's like i
couldn't think of the dude's name
it's like i knew i was like man we
watched chick cave cinema it's like he
talks about this dude all the time like
what what the [ __ ] is that dude's name
because i was so like tied up in the
birdemic thing and like james diane and
all that and i was just kind of like
[Music]
and like i said i feel bad like [ __ ]
on the dude because he seems like a
really nice man and he seems like really
earnest
which which james diane okay yeah oh
he's an environmentalist
well so you know and that's cool and
everything but it's like i feel like
he's made more movies than birdemic and
like i said rifftrax i think has done
all of them
um because i watched one the other day
that they've done if you
it's on to be i think yeah um so go
check that out if you're into that kind
of [ __ ]
so i feel kind of bad [ __ ] on him
because he seems like a nice man
but that doesn't matter we're talking
about it but honestly i don't think he
knows how
humans work no
okay i'm just thinking i'm just saying
people are apologizing sorry to
sidetrack the show
look but when you watch the [ __ ] that
move
no it's fine it's fine no no one no one
that cares about this case
is listening anymore yeah
we're like almost two hours in and so
everyone's checked out by now
yeah yeah they left a complaining
comment and they went off
and they used people never [ __ ]
talking so i'm not worried about it the
show is just oh
i forgot to tell you i forgot to tell
you just sorry to interrupt but uh
somebody today i can't remember what um
it was one of our old shows
yeah somebody commented that we were
satanists
okay and no one should listen to us
because of all our swearing and our
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] all that [ __ ] which i thought
was very funny
i just i just thought i would like
mention that because i thought it was
very funny
the thing the thing with the uh
the guy who did burdemic what astounded
me and me and jane were watching the
[ __ ] and i was just like
what what look man
i consider myself to be a well-rounded
guy
i guess in a way no maybe i'm not
well-rounded but i've
i've been around the [ __ ] block i
know a lot of [ __ ] i've always
i've always been i would say i've always
been successful with [ __ ] women
and um you know if i liked them i could
usually hook up with them
all right um i might break up with them
later
they might [ __ ] dump me but at least
i hooked up with them but anyway
dude i've never ever picked up a woman
by [ __ ] what
what i saw in that damn movie dude
sitting on a bench and sees a woman
walking
and then follows her home because
seriously if
you did that to me i'd be calling the
police yeah
there is a dude following me please yeah
help me
and and i consider myself to be kind of
especially in my youth aggressive
if i saw it and liked it i'd go after it
i would never ever
follow a [ __ ] woman home and because
it's creepy
and he go he knocks on her door and that
movie goes you know
i was just sitting on a bench and saw
you walking by and i had to meet you
the woman would call the [ __ ] cops in
which case i would mace you
yeah and then call the plates or i would
mace you and then hit you with a hammer
if you were in a restaurant and then
call the police you're in a red state
you shoot a [ __ ]
get hammer's better it's more up close
it's tomorrow yeah but yeah like i'm
saying so i feel like the [ __ ] that's in
his movies
and i'm not just gonna [ __ ] on him
specifically because
i will say that this is a trope that
turns up in a lot of like romantic
comedies
which always makes me wildly
uncomfortable because this is something
that is like encouraging
dudes to be stalkers i'm like nobody
likes that [ __ ]
yeah don't like come up to me on the
street and like tell me
i'm like oh i'm supposed to be like your
soul mate or whatever like leave me the
[ __ ] alone man
like don't make me punch you in the
[ __ ] teeth because i will
yeah and then you get mad about it
badgers saying the tangents are great
um just saying i'm just yeah
alex he just showed up
i think what no is it alex
i'm drunk i can't read all these lines
yeah oracle says it's modeling stupid
behavior it is like don't
encourage that i feel like
that is something this is why i don't
like rom-coms this is what i don't like
that kind of [ __ ] because it just
encourages like shitty behavior it
encourages like this kind of pursuit of
like
look i don't because i've had that [ __ ]
happen to me like i'm just like [ __ ]
where i used to work i used to work at
this print shop and i used to like take
a walk during my lunch hour so i
wouldn't get fat or whatever
so i'm taking a walk how many [ __ ]
times like
every other day some dude would like
pull
his car over to the curb hey i'll give
you a ride
hey i'm walking like leave me the [ __ ]
alone
and then they get hostile so you have to
like manage their egos like all the time
it's like i don't want to get killed i
don't want this and that and the other
i'm just trying to like walk and just do
normal [ __ ]
but you can't do that because they're
like constantly
up in your [ __ ] face so sitting there
singing the [ __ ] morrissey song
the more you ignore me the closer i get
you're wasting your time yeah yeah
i swear i bear more grudges
than lonely high court judges
that's a good song
[Laughter]
you guys don't know what it's called the
more you ignore me the closer i get
that [ __ ] is a stalker right
there that's what i mean that's so like
that
that's unacceptable behavior yeah that's
that acceptance
but yeah so i i do almost time for you
to take a break for a halfway break
well i'll wait till you come back from
the bathroom and then i'll go to the
bathroom
because i have a pookie video that i
shot last week i put music in the [ __ ]
and everything and then like i forgot to
do it because i was like
drunk supposedly so whatever
but yeah i don't know i don't like
i don't like any movie that encourages
stalking behavior
and i feel like a lot of james 9's
movies and
i'm sure he's not intending it he seems
like a lovely man
but hey
i don't really i don't like it i don't
like the fact that i could be walking
down the street and some like some weird
solar panels dude could be like that's
the woman for me
you're supposed to be my wife or you're
my [ __ ] soul mate or whatever
and then he's gonna follow me back to my
apartment
yeah i like that i don't like that like
i said you'll you'll probably get
stabbed right in the face
because i i'm not doing it so all right
so
let's talk about let's go back to
talking about the wonderland murders
because
holy [ __ ] i shouldn't have done this i'm
so [ __ ] sleepy alright so
we're talking about the wonderland
murders now we're talking about
[ __ ] that led up to that
which is the home invasion and robbery
of eddie nash now
eddie nash as i said was a very powerful
figure
in la in this time period he owned
many nightclubs in the area he was uh
also a known drug dealer he was very
wealthy
um he was suspected of a lot of things
but because he was wealthy
he got away with [ __ ] like you know
happens
now john holmes
aka johnny wadd because i i never get
sick of saying that
he was a friend of eddie nash in fact so
much so that eddie nash referred to him
as
his brother he was over there all the
time
trying to like buy drugs or
get drugs for free which he did for a
time until eddie nash was like yeah i'm
not doing that anymore
but so johnny nash was over there or you
know johnny wod was over there all the
time so
eddie nash had this big house there was
like all these parties going on all the
time there was all these women over
there
always something going on at the house
so
allegedly jon holmes comes back to
the wonderland gang house and
as i said john holmes at this stage was
a really bad
cocaine addict and he was getting
kind of desperate i suppose that
he was running out of money he was
running out of drugs so
he basically told the people at the uh
wonderland house hey eddie nash
has a safe under his bed and it has all
this cash it has all this
he has all these drugs he has his
jewelry you guys could just like
break into the house and steal all the
stuff because
the wonderland gank had done similar
things before they were well known for
doing that type of [ __ ]
so john holmes allegedly uh came to them
and said that that was
something that they should do um
so at this stage can i go to the
bathroom yeah go ahead all right so
commercials well i'm going to play
commercials okay well
can you do it for me yeah fe commercial
and then pookie today
okay so i'm going to do that all right
that's what you got to do
go ahead all right you ready go ahead do
the commercial
i'm going to do a commercial do it all
right i'll be back in a second
you love true crime i love true crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the ketty
murders the carrie babies case the frog
boys
the alcasar murders and the anoka shira
park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com and get ready for a chilling
journey through modern crime history
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i'm back and i'm at the con
you like the [ __ ] pookie commercial
i am the ghost of trouble joe hung
by his pretty white neck some 18 months
ago
i traveled to a mystical time zone
but i missed my bed so i soon came home
i said there's too much caffeine in your
bloodstream
and the lack of real spice of your life
i said
leave me alone because i'm all right dad
so surprised to be still be on my own
okay go ahead wow yeah you did pretty
good actually
you like that one i'll [ __ ] sing some
more to see every commercial
[Laughter]
i can't believe you sat in my chair like
yeah i was at the con man
so yeah where was i i'm talking about
eddie nash
so eddie nash i love this
that he was one of those dudes eddie
nash was obviously not his real name
he was actually palestinian he came to
the u.s
with seven dollars in his pocket
and in la he opened up a hot dog cart
and a couple years later was one of the
main like
nightclub owners in la and one of the
biggest drug dealers
so american dream [ __ ]
but yeah so he took the name eddie nash
because
when he was in uh when he first came to
la he was in like
he was an extra in a couple of movies
and i guess he was in a western or
something like that and like his name
was nash so he just decided he was gonna
like be called that
so he called himself the nash which i
thought was very funny
so this dude had this big huge house he
had all this [ __ ] [ __ ] in there and
that was like where you went to party
you went
you know you he had all the drugs he had
all the chicks were there and [ __ ] like
that
so homes have been going there and the
two of them were kind of like
thick as thieves or whatever they were
like friends
so as i said holmes was getting
desperate at this point and he
told the wonderland gang hey you guys
can like break into eddie nash's house
and he has all this stuff that you can
take
so they told him now this is one version
of the story i'll get into like the
there's another version later but one
version of the story was that he came to
them and he's like basically this is my
idea
um you guys can you know do a home
invasion on eddie nash you can take all
this stuff
and give me a cut of it so they said
okay well all you have to do
just go to any nash's house act totally
normal
and leave his sliding door like into the
kitchen of the house or whatever like
unlocked
so we can come in there and you know
pretty much shake the shake the place
down
so that's essentially what happened so
what ends up happening is that john john
holmes
goes to eddie nash's house now the day
before
the crime this is kind of hilarious to
me like in a blacklight comic sort of
way
so they had planned to do this big
[ __ ] robbery right
of this dude's house
who is one of the biggest gangsters in
la like they feel like they're gonna
pull this off without retribution
which okay so john holmes goes to the
dude's house at first
to buy drugs and he's like acting normal
he leaves
and then he leaves the door unlocked now
later in the day
he thinks to himself well [ __ ] maybe
somebody noticed that the door was
unlocked so maybe i should go back
and make sure that the door is unlocked
so he goes back
and does that it's like oh i need some
more drugs or something like that so he
came up with
some other excuse and then like he goes
back like and make sure okay the door's
still unlocked it's fine
and then he goes back to the wonderland
gang house and it's like [ __ ]
seven or eight in the morning at this
stage and he's like
okay you guys it's like it's it's all
fine everything's set up the door is
unlocked you guys can go in
and everybody in the house was so [ __ ]
up on heroin
that they were just like nah man
it was like they couldn't even be
[ __ ] bothered
to like [ __ ] they're they were all so
[ __ ] up on heroin that they couldn't
even like be bothered to like
are we to do that robbery today yeah
yeah i'll get to it whatever it was just
like that kind of [ __ ]
which i knocked out to me that was like
super super funny
like in a [ __ ] up sort of way because
he they made this big plan
and then he was just kind of like okay
let's do it it's like nah man like
leader
i'm just it's like those i don't know
it's very funny me
so so they go to the house so basically
what happens is that john holmes had
left the door unlocked
right the sliding glass door so
it's eight in the morning this gang
consisting of allegedly ron lanius
um billy deveral and david lynde
maybe jon holmes we're not real sure if
he was there or not
i kind of suspect maybe he was but we'll
get into that a little bit later
so uh tracy mccourt was actually the
getaway driver he did not go inside
um so he was outside in the getaway car
they basically they go in the house
they first say that they're cops and
this is like a drug bust they come in
the door and they're just basically like
you're busted because of drugs or
whatever and then they
tie up eddie nash they also
tie up his um bodyguard whose name was
gregory diles
now during this kind of [ __ ]
gregory diles gets shot
allegedly accidentally he lived um
but everybody said oh well the gun went
off accidentally like in all the chaos
or whatever he got shot in the back but
he lived it was fine
and um but another thing that happened
too was that
apparently they humiliated eddie nash
like they tied him up
they made him like get down on his knees
and like beg for his life
um they had to like they needed the um
you know the uh the [ __ ] [ __ ] for the
safe that was under the bed
the combination rather so they basically
like
humiliated him like they tied him up and
made him give him the um the
accommodation for the safe
now they ended up getting away this gang
they ended up getting away with 1.2
million dollars
in 1981 money damn it was a lot of money
which to me
was nowadays that's almost three and a
half million dollars
um it was in cocaine there was some
pure heroin in there there was some
jewelry
there was some antique pistols that it
actually belonged to the winter
wonderland gang but they had like sold
or they had given to eddie nash earlier
like in exchange for drugs but he hadn't
given them drugs or whatever so it was
like this big thing
and i think that was one of the things
that like spurred them
to go like hold up the place because
they're like hey he has these guns
that were that belong to us any idea
even though they had stolen them from
someone else
and the idea what and what kind of i
don't remember what they were but they
were like really
um they talked about it in the movie
somewhat but
what had apparently happened was that
they had these antique pistols because i
guess um
ron lonius like collected them
and he was gonna try and fence them or
sell them or something like that and
then like he gave them
as far as i remember he gave them to
eddie nash's like collateral for drugs
and then i guess
eddie had said either i can't fence
these because they're too fancy or
they're too distinctive or whatever
and um so i was saying true so i can't
give them
right true collectibles you just can't
get rid of them that way that's
yeah and that's i think essentially
that's what happened right
um so i think that was another thing
other than john holmes saying hey he's
got all this [ __ ] in his house i think
that was another thing that spurred the
wonderland gang to want to
hold up eddie nash was like hey he's got
these antique pistols that
if like i said they belong to ron lanius
but
they didn't really because he had stolen
them from someone else so they were
really his
they were in his custody but they were
in his custody so and he wanted them
back
so that was like another you know thing
that like made them want to hold up this
dude
so they go in there they do the [ __ ]
like i said they like
the um gregory dials the bodyguard he
got
shot but he didn't die so no one got
killed in the hold up um
but apparently eddie nash was super
pissed off
about the humiliation that he had
endured
he didn't really care about the stuff
that got stolen because like i said he
was like
super rich he owned all these nightclubs
and stuff
but he was apparently very upset that
they had
made him get on his knees and made him
like beg for his life and stuff like
that and that was something he would not
forgive so
allegedly he decided that he was going
to get some people together and get
[ __ ] revenge
for the [ __ ] and allegedly
this was what spurred the wonderland
murders
now what ended up happening was that a
couple of days
after this [ __ ] robbery
was that at 8763 wonderland avenue
los angeles it's about three o'clock
in the morning ron lonnius was in the
house
as was billy deverell and his girlfriend
joy miller who as i said was the
leaseholder on the house
and barbara richardson who was the
girlfriend i think she was the
girlfriend of ron lloyd's i think they
were like estranged
but she had kind of come back to
reconcile or something like that she was
like sleeping on the couch or whatever
now it's about three o'clock in the
morning armed men come to the door
allegedly jon holmes actually came to
the door
and said hey let me in it's me john
and they didn't have any reason to doubt
it
so they opened the door for him
allegedly
this is one version of the story
so whenever however the door got opened
a bunch of armed dudes break into the
house and start
beating all these sleeping occupants of
the house to death
with uh lead pipes
and uh various other implements
if you have seen the crime scene photos
of this
[ __ ] which i have i would not recommend
it
i'm not putting them in the video but
whoo they're nasty were the heads above
the blankets you could see
you could see the heads they were
smashed yep damn
how bad was it and there was blood
everywhere so they must have been
[ __ ] high on something the blood
was just it was all over the walls the
other ones didn't wake up was beating
one the other ones well a lot of them
were like [ __ ] they were all on drugs
you know
yes they were high so sleeping
yeah it was bad and even like the dude
like the cops that like investigate it
were like this was like
worse than the tate la bianca murders
worse yeah they're like there was just
[ __ ] blood everywhere and like i said
i've seen the crime scene
photos and i would not recommend looking
at them they're super super gross
because these people were all brutally
bludgeoned to death they find
ron uh who as i said was the leader of
the group they also found like his wife
susan who like i said was not really in
the gangs they were
actually kind of estranged but she she
lived somewhere else but she kind of
came
uh down to stay with him like to
reconcile
or to do something she was actually not
even sleeping with him she was on
sleeping on the couch
um billy deveral uh and his girlfriend
joey miller who was the leaseholder um
they were also beaten to death
so they come in
they find billy and joy in one of the
bedrooms they had both been beaten to
death now billy's body and i've seen
like i said this crime scene photo
he was like propped up against a tv
stand like
i don't know how this happened but he
was just like laying against this tv
stand
like his head is all [ __ ] busted up
and there's blood all over the [ __ ]
wall
it's like it's really [ __ ] up looking
now
ron and susan were in
this other bedroom and then
um ron was dead when they found him
but susan was actually still
alive which i will get to in a little
bit
the shitty thing is that so
apparently because this is like a
townhouse there's other houses like
right there and the house is still there
like if you look
like other houses are like really close
by so apparently neighbors when
police asked them later on like if they
heard anything
neighbors were like yeah like we heard
some screaming and we heard people
saying like don't kill me and [ __ ]
but they were so used to like a bunch of
drug addicts and like parties and [ __ ]
going right at this house
that no one thought there was anything
weird about it so the [ __ ] didn't even
get reported until like four o'clock in
the afternoon like the next day
yeah like when and that was only because
like somebody that was like he was like
a mover
and he was working in like the townhouse
next door and he heard somebody moaning
which turned out to be susan who wasn't
dead and he heard like a woman moaning
and he thought it was weird so we called
the police that was like
almost 24 hours later but nobody like
people heard screaming but nobody
thought it was weird because
they're like hey i was a bunch of drug
addicts and people were in and out like
no one thought anything weird about it
michael michael shaffer's in there
saying more people that own guns the
more wrong places crooks will break into
well i don't know what country i don't
know really country you're living in
here the united states [ __ ] guns are
not even really the problem the
problem's more of the organizations
[ __ ] everybody has guns and crooks
can get any gun anywhere
look my uncle is a [ __ ] hell's angels
there's [ __ ] going on in those
motorcycle gangs that you could never
[ __ ] imagine and it has nothing to do
with guns
there are motorcycle gangs that own
slaves
female slaves it's for real
um and you can say well the cops will be
on that and then you find out that some
of those dudes in those [ __ ]
outlaw biker ganks are cops
the corruption and the evil runs very
very [ __ ] deep
the kind of people you're talking about
in some of these organizations
it's almost like [ __ ] special forces
or cia
level [ __ ] [ __ ] a dude that i went
was in the army with his name is [ __ ]
timothy timothy vanvaccius you can look
it up
look him up on the internet he's a me
and him came up together in the army
he's probably one of the best of [ __ ]
best assassins that have ever [ __ ]
lived
who owned well had a business
in central and south america a band of
international mercenaries from germany
and poland and all they did was run
around
and train drug cartels in central and
south america
his side job was to assassinate people
you can look at his [ __ ] criminal
record i can show you pictures of me and
him together
this is unstoppable [ __ ] you can say
well he's working for the bad guys
the bad guys you were working with were
intelligence agency
agencies agencies and political figures
in
south american and central american
governments
all right that's how that [ __ ] actually
works it doesn't there is no clear
line between good and bad it's all about
money
and power especially down there in those
banana republics
nothing's clear-cut [ __ ]
con of otsulon [ __ ] he's sometimes in
the
discussions in the comments he's not
with us tonight he lives down in tijuana
and he sent me a lot of [ __ ] videos
over over the years
the [ __ ] that's going on down there with
these mexican cartels
all right
these mexican these cartels and these
criminal organizations work for a lot of
these politicians
all right it's just the way it is none
of this is going to stop forever it's
been around for
thousands of years going back to
sicarios and stuff
in the roman era in the roman empire
all this shit's dirty okay that's all
that's almost like
that's all i'm gonna say get off my
[ __ ] soapbox you sure yeah but get
off my soapbox there is there
uh we live in a bad world
and you're protected from it mostly
okay okay just just making sure
yeah yeah i'm off i'm officially giving
you a few seconds yeah
yeah i'm coming back down
okay i thought you're gonna say
something else the only person watching
your back is you
okay go ahead go ahead yeah i know i
know you too well
yeah you know i know i know when you're
like yeah you say something else i'm
just like
yeah the only person watching your back
is you take care of yourself and your
family
go ahead so yeah at this stage so
basically these people came in
they beat these people to death with
what they later determined or they
suspected were iron pipes and hammers
so this was like not this wasn't like an
execution in the sense of we're just
like trying to
um you know just like wipe these people
out
this was clearly something to
send a message because
they went the most gruesome
route they could possibly go this entire
house
was basically painted with blood
and i don't feel like the killers made
any particular
effort to disguised that they were there
there were like bloody footprints
everywhere they didn't like [ __ ]
you know they were just kind of like
they wanted to send a message is what
i'm saying
and they really did do it in the most
gruesome
[ __ ] way that they could do they
basically just went around hammered and
iron piped everyone to death while they
were
sleeping so
as i said four of the um people in the
house were
killed outright susan was still alive
now she um actually did survive
her injuries even though she was beaten
severely also
um she actually ended up
having like really bad brain damage and
she lost part of her skull
um and when police tried to question her
about the [ __ ]
her uh you know understandably her
memory was
not she couldn't remember anything all
she could remember was
a bunch of shadowy dudes coming in and
like hitting her in the face
that's all she remembered so she
couldn't remember like who it was or
anything like that
but they're pretty much i mean they
pretty much knew who it was because
here's the thing
so a couple of days after the murder
happened um the lapd
were kind of suspected that
because of the uh burglary at eddie
nash's house they suspected
that this might have been a retaliatory
effort so they went to
eddie nash's house a couple of days
after the murder
and they found about a million dollars
worth of coke
and they found a bunch of stuff that had
been
in the wonderland house and was now in
the eddie nash house which
that seems a little interesting go to
the restroom
now there are two um are you going to
that
yeah but i lost my i lost my connection
here hold on okay
so there are two like strains of thought
and like i said i like the wonderland
movie because it kind of addressed both
of these stories
both of the stories okay so one story
says
that john holmes was kind of not
necessarily the mastermind but he was
the one that kind of like
gave the gang the incentive he's like
hey look you guys
need money you guys need drugs eddie
nash who is a friend of mine
um he has all of this he he has all his
money he has all these drugs
it's in the safe under his bed and he
kind of like gave them this information
now there's a story that
[ __ ] uh david lind the aryan
brotherhood dude who was kind of like
the second in command or whatever he was
kind of like
in the gang like he didn't even know
whose house they were hitting at the
time he was just kind of like oh jon
holm said it was okay and it's like he
had all this money and it's like we just
went there and then i found out that it
was
eddie nash later on because evidently
eddie nash was very well known to like
the authorities at that time
and also very well known in the um you
know criminal underworld or whatever
um i'm not sure i buy that but they did
kind of like go into that in the movie a
little bit
like they like i said in the early part
of the movie they made david lynde like
a more sympathetic character until later
on when john holmes starts talking and
it's kind of like a different thing
but he said that they didn't know that
it was eddie nash's house
um basically they just said oh it was
like
what did they even call him the arab or
the something like that because eddie
nash like i said he was palestinian born
but he went by the name eddie nash
because that was just the name he
adopted that was not his birth name
so that's kind of like the only thing
they knew him by so it's like
we didn't know is we just thought it was
this dude that had a lot of money and
drugs and we were just like hitting this
house like we had
hit many other ones but
like i said i don't know if i buy that
but so he
yeah so he thought that that was what
was going on now
there's another line of thought where
no one knows whether john holmes as i
said aka johnny wod from the porno films
no one knows if he was actually there or
not because
even though it seems
allegedly that he did
suggest this to the wonderland gang that
they should hold up eddie nash's house
and told them where the
uh the safe was and all that other kind
of stuff which they probably wouldn't
have known without
him you know telling them
but there is some controversy over
whether
john holmes was present at the scene
whether he just let them in
whether he was forced to participate
because eddie nash basically like
took him hostage and said i'm gonna kill
everyone in your [ __ ] family
unless you do what i tell you to do
unless you let me into this house
um the thing about it is that
after he die after jon holmes died in
1988
of aids um his wife sharon who was
estranged at this time um
for obvious reasons um
she basically didn't say anything about
him one way or the other
until after he was dead and then she
came out
and said look the morning after the
murders
are like the day of the murders that jon
holmes had come to her house
and that he was covered in blood and
that he was freaking out about how he
had
seen a murder so
most people are speculating that he was
probably there
whether he did any of the murders or not
i'm not really sure
but most people think that he was
probably at least
there and was at least forced to
participate
or at least said if you don't
participate
we're gonna kill you or we're gonna kill
your wife
we're going to kill your girlfriend or
whatever in the movie wonderland they
portray it as
um eddie nash who is actually played by
eric bogosian in the movie
um that he has john holmes's black
book quote unquote that has his wife's
name and address in it has his
girlfriend's
name and address in it and basically
eddie nash says to him
look i'm going to kill everybody in this
book unless you do what i tell you
like let me into that house i'm going to
kill everybody in the you have to
participate so i have some [ __ ] on you
and then you know what i mean so you
don't have like a choice
so i don't know how true that is
but according to his wife sharon
he did come to her the day that the
murder happened and he was all covered
in blood that wasn't his
you know what i'm saying yeah so just
saying so he might have been there at
the point at the time
now uh john holmes did actually get
arrested
in connection with the murder a few days
after the crime because
they found his left palm print on
the headboard of ron lonnie's bed
in the house so holmes gets arrested
he's charged with four counts of murder
this was in uh
spring of 1982.
now basically the prosecution was trying
to sell the story that
john holmes had set up the robbery at
eddie nash's place
but then he got pissed off because he
didn't get
the cut of the uh you know the loot that
he thought
he was gonna get because he wanted the
drugs man and apparently they wouldn't
give him the amount of drugs that he
wanted or the amount of money that he
wanted
so he got mad and like whatever so
that was the prosecution story that he
was you know
just pissed off because so he was like
taking revenge and he was kind of like
not necessarily the mastermind but he
was like involved in it
now holmes's defense as i
mentioned earlier we're trying to sell
the narrative that
holmes had been roped into the [ __ ]
against his will that like nash was
basically like
look i knew you i know you set up the
robbery and i'm gonna kill your whole
entire family
if you don't participate in the [ __ ]
like leave the door open like do this or
whatever
so it's kind of like that whole
situation
so the trial of john holmes lasted three
weeks
and in june uh june 26 1982
john holmes ends up getting acquitted of
all
charges although he did spend 110
days in jail for contempt of court
because he was
refusing to cooperate with authorities
because one thing that he would do
was that he would say that he had all
this information
and then like he would get like nice
hotel rooms he would get all this other
kind of [ __ ] and then like the cops
would come and be like okay what you got
and then like he would like obfuscate
and like not
so he was trying to like get over
basically
is what he was trying to do
what about you and i'm getting starving
i'm getting hungry are you really
i'm getting [ __ ] hungry we got so
much food in that refrigerator i'm
thinking about cooking up
i can make pizza what do you think with
the hand tossed crust and everything
that's a lot of work though i got all
that
yeah you're trying to thin slices you
dropped it
i got that [ __ ] thin sliced pork
tenderloin
mexican style yeah could do the [ __ ]
tacos or i could do a
burrito with with pork and cheese
and pico de gallo in it i could do
uh see what else i could do i got some
hamburger thought
i got all that tomato sauce i could make
[ __ ] spaghetti
oh god so much with hamburger in it so
much heartburn
i know okay i'm just i'm making the
audience hungry i need to stop it
taco's be good though i need your stuff
tacos would be good with the pork
probably one with with the um
corn tortilla or flour
i got two kinds of corn tortilla i got
is that your stomach no i went like this
i got pre-made corn tortillas i can take
my second and make handmade
corn tortillas that takes longer i'm
[ __ ] drunk
or whatever whatever is like takes the
least amount of corn let's do the corn
is
likely for you to burn the house down
let's do the let's do the pre-made corn
ones when we're done
i'll cook them up in a pan okay like i
said
sound good doesn't it i don't want you
to burn the house well i have to go
afterward and like turn off because even
like when you were sober earlier on
you made some burgers for lunch and like
i went through the kitchen to like do
the laundry or whatever
like you left the [ __ ] stove on yeah
that's still vampires all right if she
can leave his [ __ ] stomach on i was
[ __ ] juggling all kinds of
i was juggling all kinds of tasks at
once i was [ __ ] doing the dishwasher
she got me in here working like i'm
[ __ ] working at like i'm in a
restaurant working
yeah but the thing about it is that the
food is good
i know but how's the cookbook going but
i it's
it's honestly really it's going really
good okay cookbook's gonna be out soon
people
i'm trying to like i said i'm trying to
get it out before christmas she's got
the foundation the skeleton and all the
photos of the [ __ ]
it's all laid out is it after that i'll
go back in there and change some [ __ ]
you gotta like go in there we're gonna
personalize it because i need some like
pictures of you i need some pictures of
pookie and some pictures of beijing to
like put in there at various points
and then after that i'll be done it's
gonna be good i mean put picture of
pookie in there
that's what i'm trying to do well i i
want pookie's like
input input i want beijing's input also
even though jake's gonna be scowling
yeah she's that cat
that beijing just constantly on [ __ ] you
status [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you she's like she's like the paris
hilton of course yeah [ __ ] you
she's that's a funny i don't know why
but i gotta get that [ __ ] on video
i keep trying but it's like she doesn't
i don't know all right
and like i said every night she gets up
and she's like murmur
with her babies do you use lara when
making tortillas you talk about them a
second tortillas nah i actually just
cook them in vegetable oil
but very very little the first time you
take the ball
you press it press the maseka ball out
i'll take it and i'll put it in almost a
dry non-stick pan
to kind of get them to [ __ ] cure like
that and then i store them like that
and then when it comes time to to serve
them
i'll take those tortillas back out that
i made and i'll a slight amount of
vegetable oil to kind of put a crisp on
them that's how i do it
but you can do it any way you want man
you cook that [ __ ] in bacon grease
i keep my bacon grease i'm [ __ ]
southern we're talking of course i'm
going to keep baby we have a whole jar
i'm going to keep [ __ ] bacon grease
man [ __ ] right
tila she's already that girl's in
california all right
you keep your bacon grease don't you
yeah hell yeah
well i mean even when i was growing up
you kept bacon grease because what the
[ __ ] else are you gonna fry your
breakfast eggs in
yeah so the southern food southern food
it's so bad for you but it's so good
tila says our desserts in the cookbook
yes they are yes yes they are
yes we're doing a whole cocktails and
desserts section
southern food i i'm i i'm southern
okay me too and i've been so she
it's it's soul food basically you know i
mean it's it's black that's
the largest section basically okay
and southern food you know there might
be more
blackish variations more whitish
variations but it's that same food
you know and it's all [ __ ] good it's
far
superior to what else is in the united
states and i say that by decree
it's a superior food so you're not
allowed to like say anything
of course you can't contradict me well
no it's against the law
well not there's another shirt it's
against i'm not lying
i'm just bragging there's a difference
okay [ __ ] when you're when you're
bragging
you're you're allowed to [ __ ] say
[ __ ] like that
but i'm a man and i have my weaknesses
and of course i like
foreign food like italian food that's
foreign food
all right i love mexican food i love
thai food japanese food
i i like honestly indian food is
probably if i had to
pick my favorite cuisine yeah indian
food and
actually holy [ __ ] i would say one one
third of everything i make is indian
more
maybe we make a lot of i make a lot of
indian i like thai food too but man
indian food is so so
i'm gonna say something everything's
good i'm gonna say something and this is
gonna
shatter the [ __ ] world you people are
gonna get upset over what i say
indian food and mexican foods are the
ultimate poor people food
and i say this because and that's not
like
no hell no the components are low-cost
components
but you eat like a [ __ ] king yep
with mexican food in it and yeah you get
the best of both worlds
it's like it's delicious food but it
doesn't cost that expensive
and southern food's kind of like that
but it's a little limited on the spice
you know you're talking about how many
grits and grits
you're talking about things that you can
do with bacon grease
you're talking about chicken fried steak
you're talking about
well you know the english style
breakfasts that we all eat but then
there's also
muffins and biscuits and i'll eat all of
it i'll eat all of it
and then there's the cajun versions
which is actually kyle you know
you you're you're which artist cajuns
people think they are it's really
product is really has a lot to do with
that that's really not that old you know
which is atop a
and [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
you know you know that yeah [ __ ] um
zach says sorry
yeah zack says i have never
had indian food what
zack you're gay you're gay well he knows
that
how can you even call yourself a gay man
never having
seriously indian food
every gay man should should it should
have been born with [ __ ]
some [ __ ] butter chicken in there up
until i ate
i didn't understand that [ __ ] i was all
kind of like oh you know italian food is
good it's like i liked british food i
like
but once i started getting into indian
food yeah oh my god
yeah everything is good
everything re indian food also it's it
has
it's a very well developed high cuisine
made out of very low-cost components
it's basically the same preparation
method just variations of the same
preparation method yeah like once you
know how to make one
indian dish you can make other ones
because it's kind of like a variation of
jenny and i went to a place this this
[ __ ] local restaurant we have here
it's called the fifth element the ship
was great before the pandemic hit it
it was great well they still do take out
and i saw we saw
basically like a long crew a white dude
with three other [ __ ] black dudes
and these were [ __ ] working class
dudes working out of the back of a truck
cutting people's lawns
and he was the white dude was showing
the black dude he was introducing them
them to the [ __ ] indians they were at
the next booth
and he was like it's like chilly and he
and his redneck ass was trying to
explain it
to the brothers and they were getting
off on that [ __ ] they ate that damn
buffet down to nothing they were [ __ ]
tearing it up
and there's something about indian
cuisine
that has kind of like a
high cuisine element to it
but it's something that a working man
can understand because it's
hearty it is very hearty and it's like
chili variations on chili over and over
again
it's [ __ ] great man and it doesn't
have to be like
i feel like a lot of people particularly
like um
americans might have a misperception
that
all indian food is like super spicy
which is not
um you can have because i don't like
super spicy food either
well i like it my stomach doesn't like
it
because i'm old but it doesn't have to
be like that
there's another thing is there's a
perception that indian food might be
made out of something weird
it's not it's not it's made out of the
same normal stuff you [ __ ] chicken
lamb and then turmeric yeah chili
plain yogurt cinnamon butter cinnamon
cumin garlic uh
ground onions that have been fried as a
as a it's nothing weird
there's nothing really weird in it it's
just a other than goat but even that is
good
even that's not that weird that's like
lamb
and that's only if you want it most of
it's chicken because that's cheaper
yeah so it's nothing it has an exotic
flavor profile
but it's only exotic because you haven't
seen it yet what it's made out of is
very common yeah it's just
it's the same [ __ ] that most like
americans would use in their
[ __ ] just different proportions and
different combinations though it's a and
like i said it doesn't have to be super
hot because i can't eat super hot [ __ ]
because
my digestive system just rebels right
but you can get mild versions of all the
[ __ ] like seriously
we go to like the indian we're gonna
we're gonna put some indian recipes in
it yeah there's a bunch of those in
there
i mean memories of india yeah there's
two of those there's
one in lake mary and there's one in
downtown orlando
which probably like the best indian
restaurant in
this area i think if you guys have never
had it
it's the basis of it is basically chili
and rice
that's basically what it is you said but
the rice is basmati
which is an almond flavored rice okay
the chili instead of being based
being very hearty and tomatoey which
some of them are
might have a more of a cream base and
instead of chili powder it might have
more
tumeric or it might have more cumin it
depends on what direction it's going to
go
but it's basically the same spices you'd
find in chi in chile
in america in chile it's not all that
different just there might be different
ratios so instead of it being red it
might be yellow
you know that that'd be a big and then
it might have cream in it
on top of all that so it'd be nice to be
nice and creamy and instead of beef
because creamer yogurt
yeah and indians don't eat beef it's
against their religion but they eat
chicken and lamb so
imagine like a chili made out of chicken
but it's creamy and it might be yellow
that's all it is garlicky it's not weird
no that would that's not weird and
honestly like
one of my favorite things from india
well other than butter chicken
which i think is probably my favorite
dish
of all time ever i love
paneer yeah which is it's just
regular flat bread with a yogurt base
instead of [ __ ]
it's a chee it's cheese but it's like
it's something opinion i always thought
you were talking
about that i thought you said nan no
well
i love not too yeah veneer paneer it's
just cheese
it's cheese but it's it's like cottage
cheese but it's a block of it it's a
block
it's a block it's not it's not it's a
very mild cheese
and honestly like
sog paneer which is like spinach with
just it's
like i said it's nothing weird it's just
spinach
and cheese imagine a block of tofu but
chewier
right but it's not tofu it's not tofu
cheese it's cheese
but it's a very very mild cheese almost
kind of like a mozzarella but
it's almost kind of like a moss but it
doesn't melt it stays together yeah
right right so it's like it's like
mozzarella it tastes like mozzarella but
it's like tofu
it's like yeah like a tofu that's a
little chewier
so it's kind of like that and
one of them that is one of my favorite
things yeah i make it all the time for
you
you do yeah but now we're talking about
food again we're going off on the food
on the food thing
people seem to be enjoying it well like
i said i'm
i'm almost at the end of the [ __ ]
crime [ __ ] so you know
i told you that i told you before the
show started
yeah i was like look i'm super super
sleepy
yeah tito's don't say she she knows
about it she
she's telling people to try the spicy
lentil stew yo hell yeah
uh i used to make the i made the lentils
too remember i remember that yeah
mental curry yeah he's made a curry with
lentils
yeah like yeah all that yeah you made
one with like black eyed peas
yeah yeah well you see some of the
western stuff is making its way into
india they'll use it
you know when i go online to go find
recipes
i'm only listening to them indian girls
cooking it
indian women i'm going to use their
recipes they know what they're doing
you know what i mean i'm not going to
listen to although
gordon ramsay went he wrote a very good
cookbook on the indian stuff
yeah i bought you that [ __ ] yeah you
bought it for him the thing is about
gordon is that gordon put the spice
level
very low real mild i'm not into that i
like to wait
i'm like like i said if it's too spicy
my stomach will rebel
but i want a little bit of spill like
more than gordon ramsay says
about three times put more okay yeah
gordon ramsay
he's over i have his indian cookbook
yeah i gave that to you
yeah he's a [ __ ] when it comes to
spices though yeah well even i
said and i'm like a wuss when it comes
to spice i'm like yeah like
up that like three times and then it'll
be okay yeah
now mexican on the other hand it's all
it tends to be
pork based um
taco really it's like they're one of
their main things that's like the
hamburger of mexico
and there's about a thousand different
types of it some of it has a middle
eastern influence like el pastor
which is almost kind of like a
rotisserie taco there's a lot of [ __ ]
that they're doing
you know when you say taco in the united
states you think of the [ __ ]
taco bell you don't remember the [ __ ]
no what they're doing in mexico
okay what they're doing in mexico is a
whole another world
they're having two taco shells on the
taco
shell the
some kind of meat on there and then they
pour gravy on it
it doesn't always have to have any kind
of cheese a lot of times doesn't have
cheese
and mexicans don't like vegetables they
kind of say vegetables suck
so it's mostly meat and [ __ ] meat
with
some kind of sauce inside of them
that is one thing i learned from that
taco chronicles show that this is
like i'm like man i like
victor i like vegetables yeah they don't
like vegetables that much
not really i don't understand mexican
culture this goes back to the [ __ ]
ad era of the aztecs
vegetables are for [ __ ] vegetables
are for [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're cutting [ __ ] hearts out
on top of them to temples and stuff
they also eat people you know i mean
they're cannibalistic
you know even the spaniards saw that
they're into making another [ __ ]
me
that that's that's some macho [ __ ] right
there
that's the macho [ __ ] right there that's
how serious they were about me
probably this is what i'm thinking
there's no reports of them actually
raising things like cattle they didn't
have cattle they might have had alpaca
and yama
okay things like that but i imagine
probably humans tasted better than those
well
the way i'm seeing it is probably the
pre-spaniard era
meat was the the food of royalty
so it took priority over everything
poor people ate vegetables so they gave
a
meat lunch that was some ghetto [ __ ]
yeah yeah that was ghetto [ __ ] so it
gave a meat lust
and you know they were war-like you know
that's what made of mexicans mexicans
were [ __ ] war-like you know these
they were badasses and they had ritual
combat rituals sacrificed it's like i'm
not only gonna kick your ass i'm also
gonna eat
you're gonna yeah and then they kick
them down the temple stairs and none of
that [ __ ] went to waste
this is according to [ __ ] spaniard
witnesses they said they didn't waste
any of those people
that they sacrificed so it's kind of
like recycling the population
you know what i mean sure i understand
you're trying so
the spaniards came they showed them you
know they brought the pigs with them
and that's how that got into the spanish
diet so in a way
the mexicans were so badass the pig was
a replacement for human flesh
well that's why they called humans long
pig yeah long it was right right
right so i'm not so hardcore that i'm
going to taste a human
it depends on what human you're talking
but i do it depends on what like
if you presented me with a steak of
someone and you said this was
someone that i particularly disliked
yeah um
[Music]
i would eat that now i grew up in
california back in the 70s
like my neighbor [ __ ] he might never
if he was a shitty person
yeah my neighbor was what really what
impressed on me his name was emil and he
was mexican-american
he was what they called chicano he lived
right next door he was he was older than
me he was like 19.
all right and i was like [ __ ] seven
or eight
and he had this badass love van
okay that they had back in the 70s
remember those yeah that's you put a
chick in the van you have
like a rolling motel did it have like
carpet on that carpet on a ceiling it
had carpet on the ceiling and yeah it
was imaginable
right well on the sides of it it had
airbrushed
pictures that covered the whole thing of
a [ __ ] aztec
dude with a [ __ ] aztec woman he's
holding her up on top of a temple with a
[ __ ] dagger like he's gonna [ __ ]
stab her
oh my god yeah he had it on either side
of it
and that was that was my first
impression
you know what i mean of mexican culture
all right and [ __ ] looks sexy as [ __ ]
she was all he's up there like conan
with a dagger
yeah yeah so [ __ ] was matcha over here
he was cool though i like that dude he
was pretty cool
yeah his dog attacked me he saved me
from his own dog
so he was yeah yeah the dog wasn't the
dog wasn't mean it was a big old
labrador and i was a little kid
you know what i mean the dog wanted to
eat you
no the dog was playing okay knock me
over and stuff you know what i mean it
was mauling you know
you know dogs do you know and he runs up
[ __ ] grabs a dog
pulls a dog off me that's when i was
about five
oh baby down yeah i was baby yeah i
remember that one
yeah i remember that damn and it was an
orange van
with that [ __ ] mural on the side of
it
man in the 70s i remember molester vans
and yeah and um the thing is is that he
was chicano he was part white his mom
was mexican his dad was white i remember
his dad like
i remember his dad his dad was a world
war ii veteran
he had those damn tattoos all over his
body
he had the two blue jays coming down on
his chest and he anchors all over his
hands and all that
and he wore the tiki [ __ ] uh you know
had a tiki theme
out in his backyard and he wore the
[ __ ] um
uh hawaiian shirts yeah you know what
i'm talking about
that was yeah
i remember all that california was a
[ __ ] hell of a place
well it was a different time yeah and
like i said
florida had a little bit of that [ __ ]
too yeah we were like the redneck
version of that yeah you know
anybody remembered a movie called the
van
i don't know probably
why do like child molesters always have
a van
because you got all this [ __ ]
all right my drink's empty all right the
drink's empty already when we can see
another one
sure hold on originally
i'm sure i'm sure it's a bad idea
okay but you know whatever
i can't uh i'm just going to put ice in
mine
i can't take
all right so what happens
so at this stage where the [ __ ] was i
so john holmes actually ends up spending
110 days
in uh jail for contempt of court because
his thing was that he kept stringing the
police along like i know some [ __ ]
they're like oh yeah you know some [ __ ]
and he's like
just kidding so it was kind of like that
kind of situation so they kind of like
put him in jail for
a while but he got out
there was a three-week trial he gets
acquitted
because there was insufficient evidence
which okay because like i said his wife
sharon
did not come out until much later and
say that hey he showed up in my house
the morning murders and he was covered
in blood
sorry i forgot to mention that at the
time but
i don't blame her because thank you
victor thank you victor
thanks victor give me a flashback
like i kind of feel like
i don't know i'm conflicted about sharon
because i don't know
why like she married john holmes before
he became a porn star okay
so i guess she had
every reason to expect
that he would just be like a normal dude
and like he would have a normal job and
like
life would progress in a normal fashion
so i kind of feel like when he came to
her and said
hey i've discovered what i want to do i
have a giant dick
and i'm going to exploit that and she
was like hey
that makes you a [ __ ] and he was just
kind of like hey not
having that and he just went and did it
anyway
and she was like yeah bye out of here
so i kind of feel like that whole [ __ ]
happened and
it's really weird because every time
i've ever seen like
um an interview with her
she seems really not like somebody that
would
be married to john holmes in the
situation that you would imagine
she seems like
um i really
hmm how can i put this without being
offensive
she seems like a very like
uh uptight kind of lady and i'm not
saying that in like a derogatory way
because
i would be like pissed off if like
somebody said but hey i'm gonna be
i'm gonna do porn and i'm just like okay
but she kind of like seemed like very
um uptight in a lot of ways
where's where's pookie i haven't go
she's probably underneath the car
i have to go check i don't have time for
that though i'm doing the show
oh man oh you want me to go out and look
for the cat in the middle of the show no
you get that song people she's like [ __ ]
you tom go out there and go look no i
just asked i just asked
she's yes i didn't say that i just said
do you know where she is
no i didn't see her pookie runs around
on the front porch
she sits under the cars she hides in the
neighbor's bushes
yeah lately since the weather has been
cooler relatively because it's florida
so it's like not as horrible as usual
she will go down to like the little lake
a couple yards down
and sit there looking for frogs but i'm
kind of like worried because
i don't know alligators they're telling
me to go save the cat there's nothing
the cat isn't in the in
in the cat is not in any danger she
better not
no no it's safe neighborhood
but alligators did you hear that
that boom was that fireworks it sounded
like fireworks
is it a holiday why would it no it's not
a holiday maybe that was the space
program
i don't know that sounds like yeah it's
fireworks
fireworks why are they lifting off
fireworks i don't know all right
what are you asking me for i don't know
tina's saying she's loving this stream
[Laughter]
tila the the alcohol is starting to
crash down on us so the [ __ ] whole
show is starting to ground to a [ __ ]
hall
how much is left on the show jenny well
that's what i mean it's like it's not
much so it's fine
okay all right so we got most of that i
told you i like i
i talked about the murders look
everybody
okay yeah everyone involved
shut up everyone involved got horribly
brutally bludgeoned to death by hammers
and iron bars all right yeah yeah yeah
but
i feel like everyone's not that
upset about it in the same way that they
were upset about the manson murder it's
just criminal
for example because they were drug
dealers
and also because like david lynn people
like that
thank you victor because jenny is going
to finish this show no matter what
that's right
yes that's what i [ __ ] do i don't
even care if i'm incoherent thank you
victor man you give me all kinds of
flashbulbs
i will not remember this [ __ ] tomorrow i
will wake up
tomorrow morning in a panic because i'll
be like
what the [ __ ] did i say did i post this
on instagram
did i do it correctly because that's
what i do
every sunday morning people she's
getting [ __ ] up that's what i do every
sunday morning she's getting [ __ ] up
i get alarmed because i feel like i
forgot some [ __ ]
yeah start plugging a book because
that's why
so i meant to mention that in the at the
beginning of the show
like while we were doing shout outs all
right
as i may have mentioned on another show
i've been like doing because i wrote
some novels
like years ago
and i've been doing like audiobook
versions of them so
one of my novels the five poisons i have
just
recently redone a print version
and an ebook version which are both now
available on amazon
as of today i also did an audio book
version of it
but i only just uploaded that today so
that usually takes like two weeks
before it shows up because they have to
like go through their like quality
control or whatever
so that will be up eventually but i did
like i corrected all the [ __ ] i did a
new
layout i did a new cover i did all that
[ __ ] so that is
up on amazon now if you look on my
[ __ ] author page
and an audiobook version of that novel
for the first time ever
will be available probably in a couple
of weeks
fiction yeah you guys will love it
that's a fiction
yeah i write fiction too all right yeah
i still have two more novels i gotta do
for that show like
novels that i wrote years ago that i
still need to do
she works all day every day almost
yeah i'm so tired i know but you know
i'm tired but i get a lot of [ __ ] done
so it's i have satisfaction
sort of but i'm also tired saria is
asking how do you get the books jenny
it's on um amazon go on amazon
jenny search jenny ashford yeah all her
books are there
all my author page [ __ ] yep
yeah like i did a first version of the
five poisons back in 2014
i think it was but i just did a
second edition i corrected all the
mistakes is it a new
layout and i did an audiobook version
but the audiobook version will not be
available yeah and if you join audible
your first book is free
somebody said that yep that is true
and also also
not like thank you hayden thank you
you're awesome i'm not like
making anybody do anything but
if my book is the first book
that you like sign up for
right when you sign up for audible i get
a bounty
yeah i think it's like 50 bucks it's
either 50 or 75 they might have like up
to
75 yeah if you join audio i'm not saying
like i don't i'm not saying you know
join audible audio and audible and your
first and and your first purchase is
jenna
jenny so you're joining because of her
she gets like 50 to 75 bucks
yeah yeah which is that's the way it was
you're still getting bounties
yeah of course i know okay like i said i
have so many up now
right but that's the thing it's like i
did that and then
the next book that i'm working on i'm
gonna do
i'm doing another five uh another uh
faceless villain
yeah this one is gonna be
unsolved murders from 2000 to 2005.
yeah also it will be disappearances
right also
there will be cases that were solved
from the
other cases that i wrote about in the
old books that were solved from
2000 2005. that's an i have two chapters
of that [ __ ] written
yeah so i'm like that's the next thing
i'm working on but i'm trying to get
this [ __ ] cookbook done too
michael says will jenny be able to
finish that drink tonight and tell you
no
she won't be able to finish that i will
but
i will be sleeping she's hammered yeah
i'll be sleeping
so
is it really like quarter to eight it's
only i know yeah no it's not even eight
o'clock yet yeah
i'm just glad i got like well it's a
three hour show though i'm glad i got
most of this [ __ ] case done
yeah so as i mentioned earlier
there is some controversy over what
involvement that john holmes had in this
whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay at the very least
he knew about the [ __ ] and he
let the gang into eddie nash's house at
the least
although investigators suspect
from later evidence that
if he didn't participate in the
wonderland murders
he was at least there
whether they made him you know
hit somebody with a pipe or what i don't
know
but his wife said later after he died
that he came to her house and the very
you know shortly after the murders
occurred and said look he was covered in
blood he was freaking out
um and he said he'd seen a bunch of he'd
seen some murders
so i don't know so
he was at least new about it right i'm
just saying
so what ended up happening um
[Music]
six years after now john holmes was
actually brought to
trial for these murders but he was
acquitted there wasn't enough
evidence if they found his paw print but
like i said you know he had been there a
bunch of times buying drugs or whatever
so it's like nobody's gonna
so six years after he was acquitted
he ends up dying of aids
now as i said earlier in the show
he had been in uh you know a lot of porn
movies
earlier but because of his cocaine
addiction
and his subsequent impotence
he had been kind of blackballed by a lot
of porn uh producers
so he ended up like being in some gay
porn and then he went overseas to be in
porn in
italy and whatnot without telling them
that he had aids so you know special
but he ended up dying of uh at a va
center
in march of 1988.
now some detectives did actually hear
that he was
dying and they came to his bedside to
see if he would give some like deathbed
confessions or some [ __ ] like that
but that ended up not happening because
he was like
essentially like incoherent
and he didn't really say anything about
being involved in the [ __ ] now later on
though
eddie nash who as i said was suspected
of being involved in a lot of
murders drug deals all kind of [ __ ]
going back from
the 70s 1980s but they couldn't really
hold him on anything
but i guess authorities have been kind
of like watching him for all this time
so
in uh 1980
or in 1990 rather eddie nash actually
did get charged
in thank you erin here's for jenny to
finish her drink oh i don't think that's
a good idea
because look at look at how much of this
[ __ ] i got
it's a whole you got a lot of [ __ ] i
know i do
so 1990 eddie nash gets
uh dragged into a california state court
um on the charge of having planned the
wonderland
murders um his bodyguard gregory dials
was also charged as a participant
because
allegedly i can't really say
like because allegedly that thing's
perfect
but people speculate that gregory diles
was
involved in the [ __ ] that he was one of
the people that did the [ __ ]
so he also got charged as a participant
in the murders
now another person that testified
against them interestingly
was scott thorson who if you don't know
was
liberace's uh boyfriend for a long time
now scott thorson was a dude that hung
out
at the wonderland house like for a while
like he hung out like in that scene
because he was a drug addict also
and um so he was kind of like
was kind of this dude that was like
hanging out at nash's house and they're
like we're
we're doing some like criminal [ __ ] so
you need to leave at this point
so he kind of knew that something weird
was going on
so he did actually like testify against
them like later on
so he testified in the trial in 1990
however
um the trial against
eddie nash and gregory diles ended up
being a hung jury
11-1 now the reason that this
happened was allegedly because
nash had paid one of the jurors several
thousand dollars
to like [ __ ] up the [ __ ] right
swing the jury for him sure right so
that's kind of what ended up happening
so he got away with [ __ ] for a very long
time
now in 2000
uh after a four year investigation
this was various local authorities
various
federal affairs they were trying to like
get this dude because they knew he was
doing
something and they were trying to get
him on something
so finally in 2000 eddie nash gets
arrested
and he is indebted on federal charges um
under the rico act so they basically
accuse him of running a drug
drug trafficking ring money laundering
yada yada
and they also charged him with
conspiring to carry out the wonderland
murders because like i said for decades
it had been speculated that he was the
one that masterminded the [ __ ] because
he was so upset about being humiliated
during the
hold up you know you're right of that
even though no one got killed during
that [ __ ]
right during the hold up but he was like
so humility is like i'm just gonna kill
everybody
because that's just how i roll so
everyone suspected
of that but they didn't have any
evidence of it
so finally in 2000 they accused him of
it
and at this point eddie nash
is in his [ __ ] 70s and he
had emphysema he had a bunch of other
like health problems
so he finally
you know they do the trial he finally
admits he's like look
it's like all right i i did some [ __ ]
like i bribed the dude in my last trial
okay
fine you got me on that [ __ ]
so they made him agree to a plea bargain
this was in 2001.
um and he said that he had
bribed the one person that ended up in
him being a hung jury
he had given her fifty thousand dollars
and he admitted to that
so they got him on that he also pleaded
guilty to the rico charges like you know
the racketeering [ __ ]
and he admitted to money laundering but
he would not admit
to being a party to the wonderland
murders
um but you know he said that he
said that well we wanted to get like
stolen property back from the wonderland
birds but we didn't like
do anything at the bus like about the
murder like he wouldn't say anything
about that
so he said well like maybe they were
trying to like go in there and
like violence ensued but i didn't have
anything to do with that that's
basically what he said
so he basically ended up getting a four
and a half
year prison sentence and he got a
quarter of a million dollar fine
and that was about it like he basically
ended up
dying like i said john holmes died of
aids in 1988.
um you know eddie nash is also dead at
this point
didn't really serve a great deal of
prison time
um as people with a lot of money
he was one of the ones that died in the
damn aids apocalypse then
he did yeah because that's about the
time a lot of them died well it's
and it's weird because i'm not really
sure when john holmes got
aids yeah um i feel like
because as many people said in the um
in the comments he had done porn
he had done uh reportedly over a
thousand
porn movies so
it's quite i mean because aids at the
time
had what like a 10 to 15 year um
you know you died in about 10 15 years
right you know it wasn't like something
that showed up immediately
yeah and they didn't know they have good
treatments for it
well not back then no it was a death
sentence yeah
which i think a lot of people forget
nowadays but
it took a while to die from it though it
did yeah
but the thing is i think people
i don't know if people like associated
with his time because he did like
do gay porn later but i don't know if
that's when he got it he might have got
it earlier because i do kind of feel
like he did gay porn like like
later on in his life probably after i
got that [ __ ]
earlier chances are i kind of feel like
he might have got it earlier
he was probably doing some prostitution
and [ __ ]
before all that happened that has been
speculated let's try what really well
because the thing about john holmes like
i said
he's like not before i started looking
into this case
all i knew about the dude was that like
he had a giant [ __ ] and he was like in a
bunch of porn moves that's
basically all i knew but he was sounding
ass
he well yeah he was settling ass
probably he was not
um a model citizen let's say that
and and like i said that's not because
he did porn because i'm not
judgmental about that you want to do
porn that's like up to you but
he there's a lot of other stuff yeah he
was like um
a really bad drug addict and he got into
he got involved in a lot of like
criminal activity yeah
to support that drug addiction
and also after he knew that he had aids
after he was diagnosed with having aids
he very deliberately went overseas
to be in other porn movies in another
country where they did not know that he
had aids
and knowingly
exposed other people in other countries
to the aids virus so
i can't feel too bad for him i'm just
saying
that's yeah that's shitty so is um
is that it on the case is it wrapped up
pretty much why you want to talk about
some other [ __ ]
no that's about it we're gonna make some
[ __ ] food man we've been doing the
show for three hours
my drink is so full still man you're not
gonna be able to finish this drink
you're gonna be you're gonna you wanna
bet me you're gonna you're gonna have
that [ __ ] up on the nightstand [ __ ]
watching movies you won't be getting
through this yet you're gonna pass out
i know you are well i probably i know
how she is i will probably will pass out
all right if you wake me up tomorrow i'm
gonna be so bad
you won't oh my god
growth if you guys were not here at the
beginning of the show that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] funny
why why do you talk that was [ __ ]
stiff man i was [ __ ] worried about it
was [ __ ] growing back
you go in there you go [ __ ] up muscle
tissue and then it grows back
and i [ __ ] was thinking that i was in
and out of sleep it was like
at the edge of it and that was a growth
got up well
as i was waking up yeah well okay
the thing about me is the thing if it's
a [ __ ] boring thing about a lot of
people
is that one i feel like crap when i wake
up yeah
okay i'm old it happens yeah
and i just feel like i don't feel the
need to make a lot of noise
like while i'm doing that i don't like
have to talk
to the room at large i don't have to
talk to my
uh your my tablet
but you do talk to you you talk to [ __ ]
yeah
what's the problem you're going on and
i'm going what's the problem you know
that's how that's
that's how george i says what is jenny's
drink it is
vodka and apple juice apple juice yeah i
mean that made that [ __ ] pretty strong
i'm out of orange juice yeah because i
didn't bother
but apple juice is actually okay because
orange juice is a
i love orange juice if it's a little bit
acidic that's half vodka
or one-third vodka i figured as much
yeah about one-third vodka
yeah that's just pretty strong erin says
tom can go cook and jenny can stay and
drink with us okay fine
fine i gotta [ __ ] started heating up
pants
go heat up some pan okay all right then
i'm [ __ ] starving man i gotta cook
i'm gonna try to cook
he's taking his [ __ ] away i'm taking my
[ __ ] away he's taking his [ __ ] away
taking my [ __ ] away and i'm gonna
[ __ ] um keep the fans
victor says go find pokey yeah that's
right i gotta find pokey too
you guys have a good night man you're
really you shouldn't
jenny will shut it down you go go find
pokey
look at this [ __ ] he left me here all by
myself
seriously
so yeah did you guys see this movie
seriously because
i saw boogie nights apropos of nothing
in the theater in 1997. thank you victor
i think you're alone now
i know i get you tiffany with them all
and like i got that it was
like probably based on some real [ __ ]
but i didn't really
look that much into it and then
maybe like a few months ago somebody
suggested
why don't you do the wonderland murders
and i kept looking into it it's like
yeah that sounds cool but it's like oh
let's put drug dealers
that got killed and i was like i didn't
want to do it but then like the more i
looked into it the more fascinating it
was
and then i watched the movie i saw the
movie that
uh was on to be and i was like man
that's a really good movie it's like
it's a really interesting story because
there's like all these [ __ ] tendrils
and i was like i got really into it and
i tried to like tell him about it and he
was just like
whatever i don't really care so it's
like
i don't know like i really got into even
though i'm not a big
fan of because i write about unsolved
murders
i write about oh my god what the [ __ ]
okay there's fireworks going on without
the window
i write about unsolved murders and i
understand that
people are more interested in murders
that
the victims are like just innocent like
i said because it's kind of like a thing
where
you know the manson murders it was just
like people just hanging out in the
house and then all of a sudden like
people came in and like started
slaughtering them
so i understand that like it didn't make
the same
impact as something like that because
these people
they got murdered in a horrible way i
mean
that i wouldn't wish on almost anybody
let's let's say that but i wouldn't wish
that on most
people um
but i feel like it doesn't get the same
attention because the
dudes or the people that got killed were
[Music]
also kind of criminals so
people don't you know it doesn't have
the same impact and i get that
but at the same time
the fact that these people were like
murdered in like
such a horrible it's it's not like they
just it's not like people just came
in and like just shot them people
came in and
very systematically just
bludgeoned these people to death
with hammers and pipes and [ __ ] like
that and i'm not sure
as shitty as some people are um
i'm not sure that that's like something
that i would
advocate and it like i'm not saying
that i wouldn't advocate for that for
anybody because
some people like i wouldn't mind seeing
that done too but
these people were shitty but you know
okay
well hey pookie came in
there's pookie
pooky's hair you guys come up on the
show come on
come on come on
no come on
oh pokey's coming there she is
hey look it i knew pookie was coming
[Laughter]
[Music]
what do you have to say about the show
poke
listen to him yeah
look at her look at her pookie
oh and she's she's sitting on the
keyboard
all right so i know you guys want to see
me finish this [ __ ]
but
yeah like i'm a this is a case i'm very
conflicted
because
i feel like getting
beaten to death with a hammer or an iron
pipe
that's [ __ ] up
like i get that's [ __ ] up but
and i don't want to side with like
a [ __ ] with eddie nash who was
obviously also a bad guy like everybody
in this is bad guys
so it's like you don't really know where
your loyalties lie
in the [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
it's like it's not
but that said i'm glad that
someone um suggested this because this
was a fascinating case
and i also got to see the movie
wonderland from 2003 which
for some reason i completely missed
even though everybody was in the [ __ ]
val kilmer was in the [ __ ]
janine garofalo who i love she was in
the [ __ ] she was playing joey miller
[ __ ] uh the the chick from friends
was in the [ __ ]
everybody was in this [ __ ] and
it was a really good movie i'm just
saying
tom left me tom left me
so i guess i'm wrapping the [ __ ] up
because he left
so
what's he real okay
[Laughter]
ken says chug chug chug oh my god
don't make me pole dance oh my god don't
suggest that kind of [ __ ]
i can't do that i can't do that right
now thank you mango
i'm lovely thank you ken i'm like
um obviously inebriated right now but
what are you gonna do tom left me all by
myself
so he could go cook something that's
hopefully delicious
sydney says i never noticed how drunk
y'all got until i'm drunk watching this
okay you guys don't even like right now
we live in sanford which is a suburb
of orlando right now
there are some explosion noises like
outside of my window
sure it's fireworks but i'm not really
sure
what they're for i don't know if this is
a holiday that i'm not aware of
yeah i don't i don't know what's going
on i don't know what's going on
zach seriously today's been shitty for
me
but y'all made me feel better soon well
thank you
what's the matter zack seriously
i thought that was tom making all that
noise well you would think that
that was the case but
honestly now that i think of it okay you
guys
somebody was supposed to come
and pressure wash our house today
called the front gate and everything and
i don't think they ever
showed up
i don't know i don't know
they never came
i test tom though because he was
handling that [ __ ]
he came in earlier i was like hey like
the people
that own our house which we rent
by the way but like they want to
pressure wash the house and i was like
okay fine and i called the front gate
and told them
to come in and pressure wash it and then
they never came
so
i don't know i don't know
pressure like i don't know man i don't
know
they need to like [ __ ] pressure
washer [ __ ] because
but nobody ever came
nobody came
gross weather zack says gross weather
guys into
ghosted me i can't get some [ __ ] from my
shark home
i know like zach
you gotta like man
you gotta like not like a bunch of [ __ ]
happens
and it's
i don't know i i try to like not
get too wrapped up in
overarching kind of [ __ ] because
it's not gonna happen hear thomas go
uh go in that kitchen
i hear noises out there he's cooking
where is dennis at um he's back there on
the shelf
tom only does dennis on very special
occasions
um i'm not actually sure what tom is
cooking
i'm not really sure he's doing out there
he opened the door pookie came in
she had a moment
i don't know what's going on out there
this is my
this is my office and this is my
entire world pretty much don't break
down this again
yeah his head broke um
tom fixed it but
i'm still kind of worried about it and
also
ken who is in the comments
also sent us an hh homes figure
which i'm kind of into
it's super cute
foreign
am i still going strong i feel like oh
this is my third drink well
i shouldn't say a third because oh my
goodness look at this
tacos look at this look
tacos
tacos i can't [ __ ] brought to me
he's like the thing about tom is that
i'm all like creative person like oh
i'm laying books out i'm like writing
books and stuff
but he's creative like in the cooking
sense
which i'm not super good at
thank you victor
well you know
i'm gonna eat this [ __ ] i'm gonna eat
the [ __ ]
everybody wants like sophie back in the
show
she needs to come back down here
she's come back down here
i'm not eating on the show is he coming
back in here is he coming back in here
okay
how long is this [ __ ] on
i will i will
you guys
i don't know if he's coming back in here
i keep waiting
i keep waiting
i keep waiting
everybody says keep eat okay
i don't like eating on tv
super hot
these are very good tacos
these are super good actually i have to
tell you
i never know what he's gonna make but
it's always a surprise he comes in he's
like hey i made this [ __ ]
like a red i'll eat it
super delicious
now i wonder if he's coming back
[Music]
um
are you guys like feeling that [ __ ] i'm
chewing it
oh man you guys
zach seriously
just um just so you know i don't endorse
that
but move on to him
because seriously he made me do like
bit shoot and
i'm not i'm not about it
so
if you want to enjoy parlay okay but
that's his thing that's not my thing
i'm just telling you right now it's not
my thing so
what true crime are you following now if
any
[Music]
um was your halloween i missed it
oh my god we had like a good show we
i was trying to talk about halloween
murders we got like super
[ __ ] up we were eating candy we had
one trick-or-treater
she was like um maybe 13
she was dressed like wonder woman it was
awesome um we gave her candy
but other than that we didn't get any
trick-or-treaters
so
that was our halloween
really good job
tim says will you be writing any more
true harmony yeah yeah
i'm doing another um bixless villain
book
it'll be 2000 to 2005
maybe and i'm going to do murders i'm
gonna do disappearances
i'm gonna do [ __ ] that was solved
in the 2000s from all the [ __ ] that i
did previously
we'll see how it works out hopefully
next year will come out that's what i'm
working on i got like the first
two chapters of that [ __ ] written we'll
see
but you know
uh halloween show was so much fun well
you know
we tried we tried
so
he is like not coming back he's not
coming back
seriously we are i've been working on
the cookbook
all day today until up until now
and i got a layout done i just got to
get him involved in like
[ __ ] doing this [ __ ] so
cookbooks take a long yeah they do it's
it's not taking like it it's taking a
long time but
once you get like the layout done i got
the layout done
i just needed his input on it
and that's taking a while but
thanksgiving food soon now i'm looking
forward to it
but i'm trying to eat so much
i say as i eat all this [ __ ]
i think you seriously left me alone
i think you left me
i don't think he's coming back
let me check though hold on
are you coming back or no
are you coming back or no
thanks
calling me back to the show huh come on
i'll be back to the show
i thought you were coming back i didn't
think you had like abandoned me
oh hell no i i said shut that [ __ ] down
give it a shot that [ __ ]
i'm i'm trying to eat yeah well
so am i but you know
this is so good it is good you guys are
so good
well i can't i can't eat because you
left me
by myself shut the stream down
all right do you know how to shut it
down i'm gonna show you how to shut it
down
we had a great night we had a great
night with you people tonight we did
three hours of show three hours and
what's that three and a half hours three
and a half hours of show
and now it was a fantastic time to say
goodbye to y'all
you guys need to sit in that [ __ ]
room that you have
have a few drinks eat a taco and it'll
be all right but go ahead and let jenny
go
better go ahead and eat see you guys
later
all right bye-bye bye you guys
thank you for hanging around i thought
he was coming back no i don't know
all right
remember like share and subscribe holy
[ __ ] you're nikki you guys know
and uh yeah
i guess i'm alone on this [ __ ] so bye
you guys we'll see you tomorrow we'll do
a movie
review tomorrow so bye